we're live we are live at uh reasons
first ever
televised webathon Telethon and the
style of the old Jerry Lewis telethons
I'm Nick Gillespie at her larger reason
and I'm joined by my uh estimable
colleague Zach weismiller uh in yet
another live stream we do this every
Thursday at one o'clock we have a
special bonus session today 1pm to 3 P.M
with a cast of some of reasons greatest
staffers writers contributors video
people Zach what is your exact title if
you don't mind my asking I'm a senior
producer at reason and region TV all
right and uh you're a father of two or
three at this point you know three Jesus
I think so yeah okay good
um yeah three is uh Eight is Enough
uh as the old TV show would have it but
three uh might be too many to be quite
out of size the father of two so this is
reasons webathon our one time during the
year where we uh ask our readers our
listeners our viewers like you if you're
watching this on YouTube or Facebook or
Twitter or God knows where else uh you
know some kind of government-sponsored
closed captioned TV and the NSA dark
room or something like that but uh to
give us tax deductible donations to help
support our journalism and our
commentary and our work on you know in
principled libertarian uh uh journalism
uh Zach when did you uh we're going to
uh run through a bunch of different
people today starting with Catherine
manga Ward our editor-in-chief she uh
she is the Queen the empress uh or the
uh unelected leader of our entire
journalism Dominion of uh you know a
print of web of podcasting a video
um we're going to start with her we're
going to run through the Bragg Brothers
Austin and Meredith who are super
producers for uh reason TV we've got
Billy Binion uh relatively new staffer
who writes a lot about criminal justice
we've got Elizabeth Nolan Brown a senior
editor who writes a ton about all sorts
of things especially uh the war on sex
uh Robbie Suave who has become his own
God demigod who hosts the rising show on
the hill we're going to be talking about
him did I miss anybody
the uh did you mention Elizabeth Nolan
Brown I did mention Elizabeth Brown who
will be dialing in from Southwestern
Ohio of all places
um uh while we're uh getting set up and
we're going to bring uh Catherine and
Zach one of the things that I was hoping
to do with all of these people and I'll
start with you
um when did you uh you know
what do you see as the essence of Reason
um and when did you get involved with
reason magazine
um I see the essence of reason as uh
trying to
have a fact-based conversation
and starting our kind of our starting
premise is that there's a presumption on
the side of human Liberty
um and so uh we any issue uh that we're
approaching we're saying you know the
presumption is it's probably better uh
if people are freely and voluntarily
able to figure things out able to figure
out social problems able to
um you know contract and transact with
each other
and then we you know can look at any
number of issues through that very like
uh wide rubric I guess and then we try
to you know always bring data to the
conversation
um always uh be able to bring uh you
know bring bring forth a set of like a
uh facts that we can all agree upon and
then you know have a conversation and so
I see it as a forum for discussing yeah
how to talk briefly uh about how you got
involved with reason
uh so uh back in you know 2009 I guess
it was I was living in La I had moved
out there just to I was oh I was
interested in video production I have
been doing kind of just like grunt work
setting up lights uh for you know small
Productions I was working at a talent
agency at one point but really um my uh
this whole time I had been a reader of
Reason uh reason.com
um this was kind of like you know on the
heels of a recent election where I'd
really appreciated the coverage there
there had been kind of like a Resurgence
of interest and libertarianism with the
Ron Paul Campaign which I was supportive
of
um and reason TV was just in its nascent
stages I mean this was yeah back at the
time when um you know YouTube existed
but it was not ubiquitous in the way it
is now and a reason TV was just kind of
hosted on its own Flash Player on the
reason.com website Drew Carey was kind
of the on-screen host uh and I saw you
know an opportunity uh that they were
looking to hire just kind of a one-year
fellow or like paid intern I was like
okay this is like a perfect melding of
my interests and journalism video
production like New Media
um and libertarian politics so I um
jumped on that opportunity uh you know
got got the position and have uh just
stayed with it hung on to it ever since
like I uh you know like a silent movie
actor hanging onto a clock you know
armband our band or something like that
do you remember what you know when you
said you read reason before you know you
applied and everything do do you
remember your first encounter with it
was it the print magazine was it the
website
was it a shady man in an alley telling
you to come closer
uh it was I do know it was the website
um I can't I'm not sure I can recall the
exact first article that I've ever read
on reason I remember one of the first
ones I ever shared on social media I was
in college
um one of these horrible you know mass
shootings had happened I think was the
might have been the Virginia Tech One
um it was actually an article uh by you
um kind of breaking down
um the reality of gun violence um and it
was just a nice uh kind of antidote to
the kind of you know very heated
rhetoric that always erupts uh after
those and I just appreciated
um kind of the
um I don't know uh like I said fact
based um very rational tone of of Reason
um and being able to you know put these
these really explosive
um and and comfortable social
um conversations and topics um in in a
wider or in a in a more
um digestible context I guess yeah okay
well thank you that's uh flattering to
hear obviously you worked uh your way up
from the fellowship as a video person to
a senior producer who's become one of
our most prolific uh video producers but
also one of our most viewed uh and later
in the show we're gonna look at a couple
of the signature pieces that you've put
out uh your favorite video that you've
released in the past year as well as
your favorite of all time but right now
we're going to switch to our
editor-in-chief Catherine Menge Ward
let's introduce her hello Catherine
thanks for joining us hey guys it's good
to hear from you and good to see you in
the wonderful reason DC office uh but
first uh Zach can we play the uh the the
clip we wanted to open with this is like
an AAA drunkalog but for capitalism
Let's uh I'm Catherine and I like
capitalism
a lot
but in my
so uh Catherine that's the barest taste
of your Ted Talk that you gave earlier
this year
um what was that like uh what were you
doing at Ted and uh had the audience
respond to uh your open Embrace of
capitalism you know it was an absolutely
wild experience it really is this kind
of
um rarefied atmosphere and people who
are there are very excited to be there
they're very engaged
um I was lucky enough to have quite an
early speaking slot and the whole
session was themed around the future of
capitalism and everyone else thought
maybe the future of capitalism was like
not capitalism anymore so much
um so I was I was the guy that was like
I don't know I think maybe we're on to
something here with this stuff and um
you know what really was striking to me
is that a lot of people came up to me
afterward and kind of secretly were like
I like
too yeah and it was like I know you came
here in your yacht like it's fine
um but the the sense of this kind of
like um secret club or this underground
or this kind of Fellowship of the True
Believers surprised me a little bit
because of course most Americans are
capitalists most Americans do like
capitalism even those who think they
don't like aspects of say their job or
um kind of day-to-day manifestations
um still benefit from it hugely so it
was a really cool experience it was uh
definitely a highlight and you know a
million people saw that thing which was
my goal so that's amazing uh you know
um very quickly what is what do you like
about capitalism the most so what I
thought in that talk and uh and I think
that it's probably actually the second
best thing about capitalism is that it
lets uh weird people try weird stuff and
then we all benefit so basically
um what I like about capitalism is Elon
Musk now you know there's upsides and
downsides to that approach
um actually my favorite thing about
capitalism is much sappier which is that
um it is the system that's based on
consent it's you know a system where you
are not forced into things and I think
that a big bummer for The Branding of
capitalism is that people do feel sort
of forced to do their jobs in a way that
I think misses the core
tenet of making contracts and buying and
selling which is um which is the kind of
double thank you you know this idea that
um we everyone gets something they
wanted in an exchange and how unique and
different that is compared with
basically every other system of
allocating labor and goods
we are I just wanted to very quickly
tell people if you want to you can look
at the crawl on the bottom go to or go
to reason.com donate or click on the
Donate button on YouTube's page and you
can make a tax deductible donation if
you go to reason.com donate you'll see
different giving levels and swag levels
of things my favorite currently is the
uh for fifty dollars you get a reason
branded stress ball which I think we're
all going to need in 2023. uh Zach yeah
the the one thing that struck me about
that Ted Talk was at the beginning you
kind of set the stage of like what has
capitalism as it actually exists kind of
done
um in historic terms because uh people
tend when whether they're talking about
capitalism or if they're talking about
socialism people try to put these in
like idealized terms like what would a
completely free market do what would
like a uh you know real communism has
never been tried but but to some degree
you know we can all agree that you know
some degree of capitalism has actually
been tried do you feel like
um there's not a broad enough cultural
appreciation at this moment of like what
the results of you know the of
capitalism have have actually been in
the real world yeah I think that
part of my TED Talk actually
um there's a whole process when you do
one of these TED talks and one thing
that happens is that you have kind of a
coach a curator who helps you put your
talk together and uh Corey who is mine
we refer to the section where I did this
kind of quick rehearsal of all the
upsides of capitalism for the last 200
years as the Stephen Pinker song like
I'm going to sing the Stephen Pinker
song
um because of course that's captured in
um a lot of his work especially uh
better angels of our nature and
um and yeah it's like capitalism done
imperfectly raised a billion people out
of poverty in the last couple of decades
and communism done imperfectly resulted
in you know horrific famines and you
know mass murder and I it's not that's
not a coincidence right like that's not
like a well it could have gone either
way absolutely not um and so yeah I do
think that there is this lack of
appreciation especially on the part of
people in the first world right I mean
it's very easy to say
okay yeah you know I have cheaper stuff
and you know maybe that's good but for
many many people what capitalism means
what globalization meant was oh now I'm
not going to starve to death like just
very very simple
um now I have now my kids can read
because we have just a little bit of
extra wealth uh in the system something
we can spend on education
birth control
Etc
um so yeah I do think it's
underappreciated but I also find you
know it's not very useful to say
actually everything's good to people who
feel like things are bad and to me
that's kind of like the big challenge
that reason is facing right now and that
a lot of people are facing right now is
like actually everything's fine we're
winning is is not a message people are
primed here and everything isn't fine
but uh you know there's a kind of baby
bath water problem
um why don't we uh talk about uh we've
asked everybody who's going to uh appear
today uh as people are scurrying around
to go to reason.com donate or donating
at the bottom of the YouTube page to
help support our journalism uh what
their favorite piece from uh last year
the favorite thing that we're involved
in from last year of end of all time uh
Catherine you became an editor-in-chief
in uh of the magazine in was it 2018 or
2016
I don't know sometimes okay and and you
but and since I think 2018 you've been
in charge of everything what about this
past year what has what what was your
pick for the thing you were most jazzed
that we did in the in this past year so
I love special issues of the print
magazine
um you know I love I love all the
platforms of Reason equally they are all
my my beloved oh you really don't but
also a special issue the magazine always
gets me very jazzed and
um one of my first tastes of power at
reason was when then editor-in-chief
Matt Welsh uh asked me to put together a
space issue um it was 10 years ago give
or take and uh this last month uh we did
another one uh I think every 10 years is
about right and uh reason has a long
history of doing these issues that dates
back to the Bob pool days uh space
Enthusiast and author of one of the
pieces in this issue
um it's nice to be able kind of uh
related to what we were talking about
before to report some good news and
there is really good news on Space uh
for many many years reason has been
saying pretty soon we think the private
space sector might really come together
and be a thing certainly 10 years ago
um you know the feature story that I
wrote for that issue and the other
pieces that we put together said that
Nick one of the very very first pieces I
wrote for a reason uh before I came back
full time was
um you were kind enough to send me to a
conference of space nerds and I wrote
about
the kind of increasing business savvy of
the private space industry then
um but it's actually happened now uh
SpaceX launches are so frequent that
they are not even a big deal anymore and
um it's sort of fully integrated into
the private sector is fully integrated
into all aspects of not just the
American
Space Race but all around the world and
that's
you know when we talk about what are
some wins for Libertarians and sometimes
they can feel very few and far between
this is a big one we really said we can
compete with the government and do
better and uh and people will will see
that appreciate it and and buy what the
space entrepreneurs are selling can you
uh talk about well let we'll talk about
the case for space billionaires your
kind of lead essay in the space issue
but let's just look at that cover again
I love that image it is so redolent of
the late 60s reason was established or
you know it came into being in 1968
um as space was dominating a lot of the
news you know the whole earth why
haven't we seen a picture of the whole
earth Apollo the Apollo missions were
underway we're a year away from landing
on the moon
um can you just talk a little bit about
that image that's just so beautiful
absolutely it is the creation of Joanne
Andresen our art director
um thank God for her she is a genius I
just kind of talked with her once a
month about what's going to be in the
issue and almost everything you see is
just the product of her fevered little
um Swedish Irish brain and uh and this
this cover actually we tried a bunch of
different iterations and you can see
some other cover candidates that we
ended up using on the inside including
you know photos of astronauts walking on
the moon but we wanted something that
felt kind of more Cosmic and more
forward-looking we also flirted with
putting a headline on the cover we were
going back to the Moon something like
that but we just thought that this kind
of beautiful silent wordless
image did the work better than a shouty
headline so it's really beautiful and
just the hand that is yearning not
really grass it's just great talk about
make briefly the case for space
billionaires and and may I if I'm
remembering correctly uh Catherine
wasn't one of the first kind of space
billionaires guys going back to that
story you mentioned just a couple
minutes ago was like the guy who owned
Motel 6 or uh Motel chain
um who shows up in a different piece in
this issue which is the UFO piece so
that's a real that's a real Arc um
Robert Robert Bigelow who is a is a
hotel entrepreneur
yeah I actually visited for that other
piece that I referred to uh the space
conference that you sent me to uh right
at the beginning of my relationship with
reason Nick I went to his Warehouse I
went to this like you know tens of
thousands of square feet of warehouse
space outside of Las Vegas surrounded by
chain link where he was trying to build
and actually did successfully launch a
couple of
um sample modules of inflatable space
habitats space hotels right
um he was a main character in that piece
he has since diverted his interests to
um funding being a part of kind of this
community of UFO enthusiasts and
Searchers
um but yes he's you know the the role of
kind of eccentric wealthy dudes in
trying to get off the planet
um you know they're they're all colorful
characters it's so odd isn't it they
they have the Run of Earth and yet
they're um yeah
so what is the case for space
billionaires people hate them so much
and so that's kind of the the original
impetus for this piece was just like why
like I get it if you're like okay you
know space isn't my thing but the rage
that was directed when a few months back
you know a couple of these guys
personally went up and uh of course
musk's
um vehicles uh are going up at an
increasing rate and um I think there are
a couple things going on one is to me
this kind of very troubling sense of
entitlement that people have the money
they spent on this somehow belongs to
the people and that it should be taxed
away and spent on whatever Joe Biden
wants to spend it on
you know to me that case is so weak in
part because we know what the government
spends money on and it's not some what I
think people who are making this
argument imagine when they say take take
the money Bezos spent on Blue origin and
uh give it to poor people that's not
what the government does they spend it
on killing people in wars and they spend
it on uh law enforcement and they spend
it on you know all manner of things
there's always just this overestimation
as to like how far the money will go I
always hear like if if only you know
Elon Musk could spend 44 billion dollars
not on Twitter or whatever we wouldn't
have world hunger anymore and it's like
if that's what it costs but why is it
why are people so hungry governments
have that money already they're spending
it on other stuff
um yeah and I think this is you know in
general we've talked about this on the
reason Roundtable podcast which people
might enjoy and therefore want to donate
to support that
um
you know even if you took in a one-time
sweep all the assets of America's
billionaires you know they're still only
covering kind of one Congressional
budget brain fart and then we're back to
zero it's uh based on your offhanded
comment about that and I think a piece
you out we did a video and it's
something like all of the billionaire
wealth in America would fund the federal
budget for like six months or something
like that
um um what is uh what's your favorite
all time
thing that you've done as editor at
reason what what is that so similarly
um it's another it's another special
issue uh the Burn After Reading issue
which we did very much on a whim
um just kind of had this idea wouldn't
it be fun to do news you can use I mean
Zach mentioned earlier you know kind of
trying to be fact-based and bring
something to the conversation and
um we thought well let's let's bring
really bring something to the
conversation and uh so we have all these
houses you can see them here you know
jury nullification how to get you know
how to hire an escort how to build your
own handgun
um and a bunch of other stuff how to get
out of zip ties how to break a zip tie
handcuff and a protest your particular
contribution uh I believe was uh how to
make uh Alice B tokless brownies right
that's right I I am always trying to
find ways to sneak recipes into reasons
probably because I am a woman and we're
just like that we love the kitchen yeah
um but uh let's do a crock pot recipe
special issue
okay and that combines so many interests
in this one as well uh which could
probably be done in a crock pot profit
yeah that's true I'm so glad that you
picked this one it's definitely one of
my favorites too
um I I just really love people who are
just trying to like put put Liberty into
action I guess you know trying to live
freely you know uh freedom is a state of
mind or something
um like how do you think about that that
kind of lived Liberty as it pertains to
reason and what we do here yeah I mean I
I have always loved the phrase
experiments in living and uh so I think
of that as one of our big beats Brian
Doherty has done incredible reporting on
many many variants of this including
your you know efforts in Honduras to
create
um you know private contracts private
contract cities and you're you're see
studying and you're and all that so I
love that stuff that's part of my
interest in space right it's an
opportunity to rethink how we organize
society and the role of the state in
that so yeah I I I do see the Burn After
Reading issue as part of this like what
is what does it look like to live freely
and I think one thing it looks like is
people my neighbors or you know people
in an adjacent City or an adjacent state
are going to do stuff that I think is
absolutely Bonkers like I wouldn't do
half the stuff in that issue I'm not out
here trying to build a gun I mean I'll
shoot them but I don't need to build
them
um the you know the beauty of the world
as I imagine it I think is a lot of
people at reason imagine it isn't
everything looks just like I want it to
and everyone is at peace it's like very
noisy and cacophonous and weird and
there's you know just across the Horizon
it's like a totally different way of
being um
that might be the difference really
between Libertarians and everyone else
right like you see cacophony or you see
not chaos but like a lot of different
things and you're like hey I like that I
don't want to go to a buffet restaurant
where it's just meatloaf in every
chafing tray that's that's the darkest
Vision yet yeah not really I wish I
hadn't said that because I won't be able
to get rid of do you remember I mean you
you have a long and varied history in
journalism how did you uh rehearse a
little bit how you came to be involved
with reason
sure so
um I was an intern at reason 22 years
ago and uh one of the most memorable
parts of that internship was like a
single phone call that I had with you
Nick because I was here in DC working
with Mike Lynch all I can remember is
that we talked about Medicare and
Nietzsche which like that's basically
still all we talk about so that feels
right
uh well to Medicare Advantage Plus
accounts or something exactly
had a couple of other jobs in between at
the New York Times at the Weekly
Standard
um but always felt that reason was kind
of my my home
um and had done some freelancing for you
and we met up for lunch and I said like
hey I'm moving to Boston do you do you
know anyone in Boston and you were like
oh it just worked for reason yeah and
that was it that was my job interview
for a reason
um I think I had to email you afterward
and say like did you did you hire me
like do we agree that you're retired and
at a rare Miss
step I actually responded to an email
yeah your first mistake and it's it
sowed the seeds of your own destruction
yes
um what do you remember when did you
first encounter reason as like a
magazine or a publication or a thing so
in college I edited an alternative paper
that was part of the Collegiate Network
um system of papers that shared kind of
a common funder and there were
conferences and things like that and at
some point reason must have made a deal
with Collegiate Network to distribute
magazines because we had a mailbox like
a box and the editor of the paper would
get ceremonial get the key to this box
um and so I went down the post office
and opened up the box and no one had
cleared it out in like a year or
whatever because that's how College
papers are
um so this enormous pile of things like
fell on my head and so I think my first
encounter with reason was probably like
an impact to the head which again makes
a lot of sense
um and I I started reading it and like
everyone I loved the brick bats like I
wish I could tell you like I saw some
kind of sophisticated intellectual
long-form feature essay and I was like
these are my people but instead it was
absolutely the funny cartoons and the
like Proto blog that was brick bats in
those days wow yeah and that goes back
to if not 1968 pretty soon after that
originally I think name something else
what do you have on tap for 2023 I mean
you mentioned before you know this is
you know it's not the greatest moment
for libertarianism that would have been
2014 perhaps but the libertarian moment
yeah should we call it that Zach I would
love to but you know mine's disagree but
what you know this is um you know
looking forward it's it's been rough
with the pandemic uh you know a lot of
economic issues obviously you know
there's a land war going on in Europe
um what what are you looking forward to
what are your big what are your big
plans for 2020 sorry
so for the magazine and for a reason my
big plans are
mostly just to try to figure out some
new ways to talk about the stuff that's
always been important to us we did a
while back a debate issue that was
really popular
um and we want to do it again because
God knows there are some new debates
within libertarianism right now and and
they need addressing one thing that I've
always loved about reason is that we are
not you know we don't do what Bill
Buckley supposedly did with National
Review which is you know who's in and
who's out of the movement you know we're
not King makers
um we're a place for discussion and um
and so I think you know there are some
there are some newly Hot Topics even you
know between Libertarians amongst
Libertarians that really need addressing
so we're going to work on that
um I'm super excited about um at reason
TV an upcoming
um you know additions to our interest in
what's going on in Latin America and
especially in Venezuela
we've got some longer form stuff coming
out from Jim Epstein on that that I
could not be more stoked about and you
know we're really experimenting with
podcasts and hoping to add a few more to
our stable so I I don't know that's like
stuff reason is doing I don't know what
I'm excited about in the world besides
more and more rocket launches but
um maybe we can we can be the be the
stuff too excited about that to be
excited maybe maybe that hand with the
Earth
you know away from it it's actually kind
of waving goodbye are we migrating
migrating happy to depart as long as
we've got somewhere to go yeah all right
well uh thank you so much Catherine for
all you do and thank you for coming in
uh you've you have a bad knee that was
shattered by listening to a Justin Amash
podcast of all things all writing on an
e-scooter it's the most on brand yeah
you could imagine and that's kind of
great that's kind of the libertarian
moment right there right yeah yeah you
know you know what I was going to say
thank you to YouTube but I take it back
now I'm not grateful to you at all
thanks for everything that you've done
and uh your long years of service how
you you know I'll just say uh you know
the the one piece I remember from your
internship which I still I think I quote
like probably two or three times a year
was about how Medicare prescription Part
D which was the prescriber the medicard
part D the prescription drugs plan
uh was needed because seniors were you
know buying cat food rather than getting
prescription drugs or whether they
couldn't afford it all and you found
that it was something like two percent
of seniors after tax income went to
prescription drugs
yeah and in general the argument of that
piece was like old people are rich
they're fine please stop and I don't
know why like last week on the podcast
you're surprised when I'm still out here
fighting the gerontocracy yeah well
maybe it's because 20 years have passed
and now I'm rapidly you know I'm waiting
for my AARP and gerontocracy membership
cards to arrive in the mail but uh now
that was a wonderful piece and I think
it's really emblematic of what we do
which as Zach was pointing out you know
it's like let's look at the facts and
facts are messy and you they're subject
to re redefinition and all of that but
like if we start from that we're going
to have a better conversation and a
better analysis about what is actually
necessary and what you want to use the
government to uh you know to accomplish
but
uh thank you Catherine so much uh we
will uh see you next year if not before
that's the reason Telethon webathon
thanks so much sounds good
okay and while we are getting ready for
our next guest uh I will uh remind
people to go to reason.com donate slash
donate uh there's a wide range of
different giving levels you can give
whatever you want however much or
however little you don't have to give it
all of course but there's different swag
Associated at YouTube there's the Donate
button
um Zach what uh
you know can we also just uh and I want
to encourage people to ask questions
both of us and the guests coming on
right you have a little cue of comments
I'll pull a few up
um but uh one is uh Rick Neal Jr I've
recently been watching a bunch of
hilarious recent TV content uh and I
think our next guests uh are going to uh
be their their the brains behind a lot
of that um yeah I wish something like
this had been more ubiquitous when I was
raising my young kids
um so yeah I mean that's what I that's a
pretty good segue into uh I believe uh
Meredith Bragg and Austin Bragg the
Bragg brothers are ready uh to talk
there's Meredith
we talk badly about your brother your
younger brother I'm assuming he can hear
me so anything will just come right back
where did he go he'll be here in just a
minute okay but uh yeah
um
well now we're kind of at a a loss
why are we talking to you with the team
I like his VFX and style yes Lex
um still works for a reason he does a
lot of the graphic design for the
website
um and yeah very very talented guy
um here's Austin yeah
hey
Austin Brad can you hear us I can hear
you can you hear me yes we can thanks so
much it's good to see uh Austin and
Meredith Bragg who Brothers uh you are
your two of three Bragg brothers and you
two are the least successful correct
right yeah the one who isn't involved
with reason is the when your parents
actually still talk to right we have a
doctor for an older brother so our
parents sort of take their hands off and
claim their successful son and let us be
but when they need a puppet video they
come to you right where else would they
go right yeah yeah
um well let's uh you know this is the
reason.com slash donate webathon
Telethon uh we're filling up the screen
so you can't see the Jerry Lewis style
uh backdrop which luckily Vienna uh
velena uh actually designed for us
um but Austin and Meredith why don't you
um start or Zach why don't we start do
we have a clip to run introducing them
or how are we going to do this uh yeah
sure
um I I believe uh you know one one of
you had mentioned this as kind of the
the highlights from this year and I I
totally agree so let's just uh play it
and then talk about it
foreign
[Music]
Squad series who uh we were asking
everybody what's your favorite thing
you've done in the past year end of all
time uh which one of you uh pick crime
Squad that was me
um yeah we've that sort of idea has been
brewing in the back of our heads for a
long time
um I I think partially uh at least
partially due to the Twitter feed crime
a day which posts a bunch of these just
inane regulations
um and we had these puppets sort of left
over from previous videos that we had
done like the libertarian PBS or some of
the other things and uh it just seemed
to be a natural fit that we could create
these quick
just brutal interactions with police uh
that are nonetheless rooted in
ridiculous true laws do you feel like
your puppetry skills have improved over
time
no it's a nightmare yeah it is much
harder we have a lot of respect now for
puppeteers yeah and I appreciate all the
comments uh telling me not to flip the
top or whatever it is I don't know I'm
still learning I'm sorry maybe reason
can pay for a continuing education class
in puppetry is is mine next for you guys
then are you like going through the
things we hate the most and we're going
to master them precisely
uh what is what what kind of response
have you gotten to the puppet videos
because I and you know and obviously
it's I mean if they're brilliant and
it's great to take something so kind of
childish or associated with that and
make it so
you know serious but
um what kind of what what's the response
Ben
uh it's been good quite good there's
been plenty of people you know in the
comments highlighting uh you know the
dumb laws that they're personally aware
of uh around them that they want us to
to push forward but um yeah it's been
quite good it's it's short it's you know
it's very quick most of these videos are
what a minute and a half two minutes
um but uh it's been pretty positive but
you've never feel so alive is when you
have your hand up a puppet's butt right
and you're holding it up for the green
screen and things I'm gonna let that be
your quote Nick not mine okay yeah I you
know I think about it a lot I haven't
tried it yet but it shows you know we
did pass on Jeff Dunham you know we
could have had Jeff Dunham here so you
know give me a little bit more guys sure
I will say uh there are moments where we
are throwing police puppets at another
puppet
um which happens in every video that um
we do like to remind ourselves that this
is our job yeah yeah I went to college
for this yeah
Meredith what was your what's your
favorite uh video of the year
of the year uh I chose Disney okay let's
uh let's show that the conservative
amusement parks with hidden liberal
agendas are you sick of woke
progressives ruining you let me start
that from the beginning we got a little
are you tired of amusement parks with
hidden liberal agendas are you sick of
woke progressives ruining your family's
vacation are you white well come on down
to Republican Disney you don't have to
be white that's just it that was a
demographic survey question for
marketing purposes I don't see color are
you tired of amusement parks full of
bigotry are you sick of uneducated Rubes
ruining your family's vacation do you
crave fun and guilt well come on down to
democratic Disney we're the only
amusement park in America exclusively
dedicated to diversity Equity inclusion
real science true history and other
morally unambiguous things that we can't
debate anymore because of Nazis
Republicans
that's great and I just I I think I
liked it so much because it was the
jokes per minute are pretty high
especially um as you keep moving it's uh
and there's probably stuff in there that
every you know you will hate at least
one thing and like about three more and
I think that's probably a pretty good
balance
um but it was also uh they're these
characters that Austin and Andrew Heaton
uh have sort of created during uh for
the Amazon HQ video which I also adore
and could have easily been on my my
favorite list
um you sort of Republican sort of
typical Republican typical Democrat
politicians and this was a way to
explore that um
we're so used to doing or for a long
time we've been doing these libertarian
blank videos you know libertarian Game
of Thrones libertarian Star Trek
libertarian Star Wars and those are
great
um but this just gave us another angle
into that sort of genre for us so yeah I
just find it very funny there are a lot
of lines that just still make me chuckle
what are some of the like most valuable
things that you see in political satire
or political comedy you know as a tool
to critique or reveal things about
American politics
um I do think and you know this is not
anything novel on my end other people
have said this before but I do think
that sometimes
um
when you're making a joke people are
laughing they may be a little bit less
defensive than if you're just making a
pure argument
um and
uh
so it's a nice way to just sort of if
not change people's minds at least
um
maybe open the door a little bit to
understand where the other side is
coming from and in so many you know I I
was listening to you talked to Catherine
before about
um you know experiments in living and in
so many ways I think that's sort of my
world view and that doesn't mean
necessarily stopping other people or
pushing other people into your Camp it
means allowing a lot of different
experiments and so I think understanding
how other people uh feel and maybe
sometimes humor can do that it's just uh
it's a it's a fun tool that's the other
thing I think it's sort of a humor in a
lot of ways even The Gallows humor in
some respects is pretty optimistic I
think if you're making jokes about
something and that's something you know
I like I've always liked reasons
optimism it's something that really drew
me to reason as a magazine but it is
balanced by some really great Gallows
shoes oh it's dark that's Camp humor
yeah and why don't we uh one of you
picked the libertarian dad jokes as your
favorite
uh comedy video or video that you were
involved with of all time can we cue
that one up because that is really a
kind of uh paradigmatic Communists used
to light their houses before candles
electricity
hold on let's cue this up
but
um
I asked my North Korean friend how
things were going there
he said I can't complain
yeah
uh why did the libertarian quit his job
at the Italian car factory
[Music]
because he hated Fiat
[Music]
Fiat
[Music]
how do you know Arlington National
Cemetery is popular I don't know how
because people are dying to get in there
during the all the Foreign Wars without
Congressional authorization
to die overseas and then the body is
shipped back home yeah no I get the
mechanics of it the families come and
visit the graves and it's uh
it's pretty crowded I am not sure that
joke works yeah well neither does nation
building but people keep trying it
okay
Ah that's wonderful stuff
yeah I mean I think that was another one
of those I think we had brought Andrew
Heaton in for um another sketch one of
these marketing sketches and this was
something we had come up with if not
while he was on the ground just days
before and so we quickly compiled it and
we tried it out and what I love about it
is that there's a narrative Arc
throughout it it's not just a Gatling
gun but there is a beginner middle and
end so it feels more like a whole sketch
but that the jokes themselves are both
terrible but also take a turn you
wouldn't expect them that's one of my
favorites you guys do a great job of
mocking or yeah mocking might be too
strong a tour but like I mean you make
fun of libertarian stuff so when it's
libertarian PBS or you know libertarian
Game of Thrones which I believe we also
have queued up yep um the in-jokes are
fantastic so I mean you're reaching out
to an audience but you're also
speaking to us specifically libertarian
audience Austin I guess this was your
favorite pet yeah it was so let's yeah
let's watch a clip of this and uh talk
about it the crown is three million in
death actually it's 20 trillion how
could he let this happen entitlement
spending a bunch of wars that bullet
train to River Run didn't help
the Social Security trust fund where all
of the money goes that will one day be
paid out to retirees
nothing yeah that's pretty much party
scheme
yeah we had a lot of fun with that one I
think we
are lucky enough to work at reason and
uh you know reason gives us enough time
to to Really dive into these in
pre-production and get things right
um and that was one of those scenarios
where I think we had Andrew in here a
couple of times uh reworking some of
those bits just to make them fit
um you know obviously we had done these
libertarian things before and I I want
to Echo what you said before I think
it's important that we we do uh hit
ourselves as well right we do need to uh
look at libertarianism and what we're
putting out into the world and
um you know we we deserve some jokes too
uh we are uh you know this is part of
our reason Telethon or uh you know our
our yearly annual webathon go to
reason.com donate or hit the Donate
button at the bottom of the page at
YouTube and you can make a tax
deductible donation and your money goes
to support people like uh Austin and
Meredith Bragg uh as well as Andrew
Heaton who showed up first I guess in
with reason through mostly weekly
um the series that we did for a while he
had Sarah siskin wrote
um can you uh I guess let's talk about
how you first came to uh experience
reason like you guys you grew up in
Northern Virginia
um but like do you remember was it the
older brother wasn't it uh Meredith who
introduced you to reason I know that he
um he was definitely interested I think
we had watched a because we're very
interesting people we had watched a
Libertarian
um uh uh
can we watch it on C-Span they were um
and uh
he got interested in it and for
Christmas that year I went to the
libertarian party headquarters and
bought him a couple books which at that
time I think was in the Watergate if I
remember correctly
and then that Christmas I proceeded to
read it and I got interested in it and
um I I'm pretty sure that he had he was
the first person to introduce me to
reason
and then when I came back
um you know I went to work in journalism
after school
um
went was was living in Charlottesville
for a spell when my wife went to grad
school there
and then when I came back into town and
Austin's going to sort of pick this up
Austin gave me a call or sent me an
email and you want to pick up the story
here because
sure
um I at the time had uh I was working at
the Cato Institute in their video
Department
um and
um I remembered sort of now that I'm
firmly ensconced in the libertarian
Mafia here in DC uh hearing that reason
uh had a job opening and at the same
time you know
Cato wasn't doing the sort of things
that reason was and I remember calling
up Meredith and saying I think I found
something for you
yeah and I I mean I had assumed that I
would go back into journalism I wanted
to do video
um
the idea of doing comedy was appealing
but never thought that that would be my
job the idea of doing sort of lowercase
libertarian comedy journalism was just
out of I mean that didn't exist reason
basically built that and
um so I was very grateful to check boxes
that I didn't even know I could check
and um you know I came here almost a
little over a decade ago and I've been
here ever since I mean and for a while
you were the executive editor or
editor-in-chief of Reason uh tv as well
yeah and you hired me so thank you Nick
yeah yeah well I got a lot to answer for
but I'm pretty sure I came in with Zach
right like I was hired when you came out
as well right Zach I think he was at
West Coast you were East Coast so right
Zach and I shared an office very briefly
that's right yes that's a strange
building on uh Sepulveda oh yeah yeah
um what uh what do you what do you have
uh planned for the coming year and and I
guess our we're at Liberty to talk about
you you before you came to reason you uh
had produced a couple of uh like web
programs for Channel 101 a pioneering uh
kind of web uh based series
um and a documentary uh full-length
documentary um but you've got a feature
film that you've done through the moving
picture Institute can you talk a little
bit about that and what's up with that
sure so
um uh MPI original films who we worked
with for a short film we had
um called a piece of cake that came out
in 2020 or was supposed to come out in
2020 uh it was supposed to Premiere at
Tribeca but it ended up with kovid
having a very nice version screening
Festival run
uh
we made a feature film with them last
year and it's just about two months ago
started on the film festival circuit and
premiered to The Hamptons it's called
pinball the man who saves the game or
saved the game and it is a
biopic based on a true story of Roger
sharp the man who helped legalize
pinball in 1976 in New York City by
proving that it was a game of skill and
not chance and it's had a wonderful
Festival run
Hampton's Savannah Newport Beach
Heartland won a number of awards been
very well received thankfully I think
we're Austin and I are both relieved you
never know when you do these things
and that will be
coming out on VOD in the spring
is the Hope and we're just sort of
waiting to hear more at this point but
um yeah it's been fantastic and as far
as what we plan to do at reason I could
tell you the next year Austin and I
would like to especially now that
covet's over and with the
the short and the feature under our belt
we want to take some of the lessons that
we've learned doing that and create sort
of
Marquee sketches for reason so taking
some of what we've learned by working
with others primarily Austin and I work
together just the two of us on the
sketches for reason for the short and
for the future we had a crew and
um we started to see the value in in
some of what they were able to do so
with that what we're able to do with the
crew of that of a certain size and so we
would like to take some of that
knowledge and bring it to reason and
that's our hope for the future is
marquee sketches in the vein of key and
peel getting out outside the green
screen more going into locations
and creating sort of
big you're better more yeah just uh push
push what we can do push them is the uh
you know the ones that we had talked
about this a lot but never were able to
pull it off what a reason snuff film is
that uh yeah again um I think that's on
your neck we'll let you okay yeah
let me just uh tell uh everyone watching
that you should be very excited about
this pinball movie that'll be uh you
know available soon I had the pleasure
of meeting up with uh Meredith and
Savannah to watch it at the festival
there and um it was great uh the
audience loved it uh I loved it it was
uh like it's really funny and charming
and and yeah it does have this weird
like quirky
um you know uh libertarian story at the
center of it
um about you know Banning pinball uh
which is just bizarre but
um I'm just I was just really impressed
with how it came out and um yeah you
guys are just all always pushing the
production values of Reason TV up and up
just like watching that game of thrones
thing again it's amazing the way you're
able to you know match the footage uh so
yeah we're we're lucky to have you uh on
the team and we're gonna talk oh sorry
no especially when you're talking about
this film I know it's normal for
journalists to take book leaves and you
know and write their book but you know I
think it's a little slightly odd for us
to take film Leaf uh and jump you know
come right back after a few months uh
it's been it's been a great experience
uh talk a little bit about Remy
um because uh Remy joined started doing
videos for reason around the time I
guess Meredith When when you joined or
he might have done one or two before I'm
not sure but yeah yeah he came in a
couple of years after yeah and I think
it was a couple years after eating okay
yeah uh but uh talk about that because
you know Remy's uh videos the the
musical parodies uh he was well known
for doing you know kind of less
certainly less libertarian oriented
things but he was very popular in
YouTube but like he's you guys working
with him have really created this
sensibility that is unique
yeah I mean I could just say that um you
know at this stage we've probably worked
with Remy almost 10 years I think we're
coming up to maybe I should count the
number of videos it's got to be you know
dozens and dozens and dozens maybe 50 or
so videos that we've done we have
another one we're working with him on
now
um that we'll shoot next week
um and can you uh give us a preview what
is uh what hilarity will ensue it's a
cryptocurrency about current news let's
just say that okay very good very good
um he uh and and I would you know
Remy is one of these wonderful people
like Andrew that not only do
they bring us wonderful work and they're
great on camera and they're wonderful to
work with but they've just become really
good friends and we've I mean he's like
we've created this bizarre
comedy libertarian comedy Voltron uh out
of the the four of us that we really
like
um
we really like each other we like
working together and so looking for any
opportunity but uh yeah Remy's fantastic
and I'm you know
where it's always fun to jump on the
phone and sort of try to come up with
visuals for the songs that he's written
and figure out how we can
improve something make it a little bit
more ambitious if I may uh you know one
of the I I would have picked for and you
were both involved in it uh Meredith I
think you were the primary scripter but
Austin has a key role as the voice of
John Adams uh the attack ad Circa 1800
Right video like awesome I mean people
go and watch that it's so [ __ ] funny
and it's Timeless I mean it's 200 years
old and it's Timeless but also how did
you come up how did you envision John
Adams voice how did you get into the
role what is your man like how did you
find that character well as an artist
um I don't know I mean you just take a
look at the words on the page and a
couple of images and
I mean the whole point is that it's
Timeless right the whole point is that
all of these people have been sniping
and saying terrible things at each other
for ever and so
um you know I don't even remember what
that voice was other than slightly
trollish
that's about right yeah and but it was
great because it's you know like the
only John Adams that I had seen was like
in 1776 where he's the hero and like the
David McCullough book and miniseries
where he's the hero and he's well yeah
but even so Giamatti is kind of trollish
yeah yeah yeah so
um that's it's uh really wonderful uh
Zach do you want to ask them a final
question
um yeah so
um oh sorry
let's see uh
I mean you know talk a little bit uh
about
um
like what I liked what you said about
um how you uh you allow everyone to
laugh at themselves that's what I like
about
um kind of the libertarian Game of
Thrones parody
um is people having a sense of humor
about themselves usually enables
conversation and dialogue and and and
maybe you know breaking down
uh some of the hostility that we have
seen in in recent years between the
different political tribes
um do you ever think about that in
um you know as as part of your project
is is like facilitating
um some sort of understanding between
different sides
awesome to let you take that one
I'm not a thinker
truthfully I mean I go into these things
90 of the time thinking about the comedy
first right I mean obviously we have uh
a mission you know we need to stay on
brand uh which you know isn't difficult
for either of us or any of us I should
say uh when you're adding Remy and
Andrew into the mix
um
mostly we just want to up the jokes per
minute and and get the comedy in there
um everything else sort of falls into
place really because I think when you're
when you're coming from that ideological
perspective and you're cracking jokes
you're going to hit people differently
comedy is so subjective everyone's going
to take something different from it one
of the reasons that I think we try to
pack it in you know Gatling gun humor is
that nobody's going to get them all
right
um you know
I keep going back to the same example
from the uh libertarian Star Wars which
is
um uh free to Chewbacca right it's this
tiny little thing it's 20 seconds long
it's one of my favorite bits I think 80
of the people who watch that have no
idea what's going on they're just
confused I think it's hysterical and the
people who get it are hysterical right
it's going to hit everybody in a
different way and so
for me it's just about maximizing that
um
potential
against the walls I can't and again it's
been a while since I've looked at the
YouTube comments for that video and
maybe after this I'll go check it out
but I'm pretty sure that whenever we do
something that's you know Niche
um
people in the comments will ask I don't
understand this and other people will
explain it and it's in some ways it's a
Gateway if people want to learn more
about it they're welcome to
these comedy videos I promise you you're
not going you know the you may learn a
thing you know one or two things but
this is not a white paper there are
people who make very good white papers
and you should read them if you're
interested in the subject
but it may spark someone to figure out
what free to choose is maybe watch like
who Milton Friedman is like it's it can
be a gateway to a larger conversation
but we don't pretend that we are solving
all the world's problems in a two-minute
puppet video or that we can explain it
all and in tune I mean we've been pretty
blatant about it too there have been a
couple times where Heaton literally
turned to the camera and said eminent
domain Google it
yeah Frida Chewbacca in particular
people have come up to me referencing
that so I can't imagine uh how many
times uh you know people have brought
that up with you that that it hits some
weird chord I'll tell you the Aleppo
joke from
um Dad jokes is one of those things that
has been repeated to me and I'm not sure
they know that I am
partially behind that joke
um uh which is great like when you you
know these things are parroted back to
you in such a way you know you're
hitting hitting something right well you
guys have uh I mean the hits keep coming
uh so thank you so much for your
contributions to what reason stands for
and what our possibilities are you've
really enlarged it and continued to so
thanks very much
um if I could just say one more thing
before because I do think it's important
to say this
um there are very very very few places
if any that would allow us to do the
sort of things that we're doing I mean
truly the fact that we get to we get the
autonomy uh to do this and to try and
experiment and to create these on paper
truly bizarre videos
um and I cannot think of another place
that would allow us to do this it's um
reason is really special in that regard
in many regards but I'm being selfish
here in that regard
to fail which we have yeah
I don't know I'm very good at helping
I'm I'm a good failure Sherpa
I'm the tensing Norgay of failure uh
thank you Austin Bragg Meredith Bragg
for what you've done in 2022 and what's
coming out in 2023 including uh the
feature film thanks thank you thank you
and a reminder if you dig what Austin
Bragg Meredith Bragg what did Andrew
Heaton and what Remy do as well as other
people had reason TV uh whether it's
comedy or tragedy or documentary or
interviews go to reason.com
donate and you can give a tax deductible
gift that will help support our efforts
in the coming year and thank you to some
of the specific donors who've already
thrown in a very generous gift from uh
Harry katakalitis 406 dollars right we
had um another we've had some Anonymous
uh hundred dollar donations
um there was
uh lee lee McLaughlin gave a hundred
dollar donation so thank you for
everyone who's uh thrown in to help this
work uh I I want to Echo you know what
uh Meredith and Austin just said you
know the reason gives me a lot of
autonomy to
um kind of explore the topics I'm
interested in
um and just kind of explore new uh forms
as well uh you know forms of expression
um that was what initially attracted to
me to reason TV is it was at the time
you know on the Leading Edge of you know
the New Media uh digital video type
Revolution
um and they we've continued to evolve
and and learn new things in a really
Nimble way and it's like it's just the
the culture here and uh it's uh uh I
appreciate everyone who's allowing this
platform to to continue on uh with that
Evolution yeah and uh you know as we're
getting ready for our next guest who is
Billy Binion we'll get to him in just a
second but one of the great things about
reason TV if I may say so as the person
was the first editor-in-chief of that it
was the brainchild of Drew Carey who
basically came to reason in two late
2006 early 2007 it launched eventually
in late 2007 but he was like you know
technology camera technology editing
technology online video had become a
cheap possibility like you could do it
and we really ran with the kind of
innovation that was born out of
technological change uh Jim Epstein
who's the current executive editor of
Reason TV who oversees all of our video
products uh wrote a fantastic piece uh
uh for the magazine God I think was in
2014 about a particular Sony camera that
just changed the way that people could
do high quality video work can kind of
distribute it and um you know so reason
TV in a lot of ways is not just the way
of telling people you know what
libertarian ideas are about and staging
conversations debates documentaries
investigations and things like that it's
an enactment of of kind of the world
that reason sees one that is comprised
of free minds and free markets and of
innovation experiments and living and
you know trying to figure out what comes
next and how can we use any whatever's
out there to express ourselves and to
actualize ourselves
um before you bring on Billy let me just
throw out one more thank you we just got
an anonymous one thousand dollar
donation so thank you very much to
whoever just threw that one in this is
very exciting this is like a real uh
Telethon yeah
yeah so if only uh but let's bring in uh
Billy Binion now who is a staffer who uh
writes a lot about criminal justice and
related issues Billy thanks for joining
us today thanks for having me can you uh
what is your actual title at reason I'm
an associate editor no and you joined
the staff uh when
January 2019 I came on as an intern and
did that for three months and then they
asked me to stay all right well thank
you for everything you're doing you've
become a real traffic champ at uh
reason.com in particular uh you write a
lot about uh criminal justice uh issues
Criminal Justice Reform policing things
like that what was your uh what was the
story in 2022 that you were most proud
of
yeah so the story that I think I was
most proud of from 2022 was a story
about a woman named Tracy McCarter which
you probably have not heard of
um or as a person you've probably not
heard of it didn't her story didn't gain
much traction in the national press when
it comes to places like you know the
Washington Post or the times that sort
of thing but the reason this really
kind of stuck out to me is one of the
things that I love about reason is that
we're not really on a partisan team
we're not wearing a jersey
um and so this story kind of epitomized
something I've always thought a lot
about which is that principles don't
mean anything if you don't apply them
evenly so this district attorney who I
think a lot of people are familiar with
now he is the Manhattan district
attorney Alvin Bragg who campaigned no
relation to Meredith and Austin Bragg
just want to make sure that's clear
no definitely not
um
but he ran on a platform of
quote-unquote ending mass incarceration
reforming uh pre-trial detention that
sort of thing like a big criminal
justice reformer and he actually
specifically campaigned on This Woman's
case he said that you know if he were to
win office he would drop the murder
charges against her
um she was indicted for stabbing her
highly abusive estranged husband who
came into her apartment though he did
not live there and threatened her all of
there was plenty of evidence that was
self-defense he had said on the record
it was self-defense he had said I stand
with Tracy and then he gets into office
and continues to prosecute her for
murder and subjects her to very strict
pre-trial bail policies because at the
end of the day just attorneys are also
political actors who are trying to
please
um
a base instead of fulfill their promises
and so the point that I was trying to
make with her piece with the stories
that I wrote on her piece was that if
you really believe in what you say about
things about ending mass incarceration
and wanting a more fair and just system
and that also has to apply to things
like self-defense which is not as
politically expedient but is very
important you also saw that with Jose
Alba who I covered for us quite a bit I
wrote several pieces on hand the 61 year
old Bodega worker in New York City who
essentially stabbed an irate customer in
self-defense there was plenty of
surveillance video corroborating it from
different angles
um their long altercation you know
but yet the criminal justice reformer
took him to Rikers one of the most
notorious jails in this country and
initially sought 500 000 bail to keep
him there despite running on promises to
reform pre-trial detention so
these cases are really important to me
because I feel like it is so vital for
places like reason to continuously point
out that if you only apply your
principles when they're politically
expedient and they don't mean anything
and they're not principles
hey Billy uh first of all I just want to
pull up this comment Billy is one of my
favorite reason writers his stories all
get always get me so fired up
um another one here
Bill Binion is good especially
considering he's apparently 12 years old
uh but Billy you know these stories
um it it what it raises for me is like
the role of Libertarians in the criminal
justice like reform either you know
movement or just like talking about
Criminal Justice Reform uh issues
because you're talking about you know
this is a coalition that involves
Libertarians progressives uh some
conservatives
um and they might
each of these groups might have certain
blind spots in certain areas right so
what do you think um is like the
importance of Libertarians staying
really engaged with like criminal
justice type issues yeah well I think
Libertarians I will never forget I I
doubt my old roommate is watching this
but one of my good friends who I used to
live with when we were getting to know
each other better said something like
well I just thought Libertarians were
Republicans with a conscience
essentially like Republicans who like
believed in social issues
um and that are believed in you know
social like a marriage and that kind of
thing
um
and I think that's probably because a
lot of like the highest profile
Libertarians or libertarian leading
people in Congress do kind of lean more
to the right but I think like I'm saying
if you if you are if you kind of look at
the world through libertarian lens and
you apply those principles very
consistently across the board that does
mean that you're going to be this like
really weird heterodox mix uh views that
will both you know please some people
but also piss a lot of people off I have
never been someone who has like a
political witness test for who I'm
willing to like talk to or work with I
think on if you look at my portfolio
like I propose of nothing you might
assume that I'm like on the left I'm
obviously not on the left
um but that's to me just another
indication of the fact that if you do
have these principles you know whether
we're talking about Free Speech whether
we're talking about criminal justice
issues whatever you also have to apply
apply those principles to people that
you find really unsavory and I think
that is something that both Republicans
and Democrats can learn from us uh is
that
you know if you believe in Criminal
Justice Reform that also has to apply to
the Jose Aldos and the Tracy mcquarters
of the world if you believe in free
speech that also has to apply to people
who are saying really gross offensive
things that sort of you are you are
Jiminy Cricket right wow that's I'll
take that as a compliment it is well
you're a conscience right uh you're a
conscience okay
you know uh we will happily call you
whatever Disney character you I identify
as the blueberry from Pinocchio how did
you um how did you come by libertarian
ideas and beliefs I mean we've talked at
various points so I know a bit about
your biography but uh do you remember
how you first encountered uh reason or
libertarian ideas I do
um so I guess I was always one of those
people in college who had like the very
like
oversimplified like I guess I'm a little
socially liberal and fiscally
conservative which now like makes me
kind of cringe because it's so like
doesn't exactly
represent what we do here but um
it didn't really come until so I used to
be a performer I majored in voice and
like that was my first career and we
might get into that later but when I was
disenchanted with that and was like okay
I think I want to work in journalism I
was looking uh online for journalism
fellowships and I came across this
Fellowship that a kind of enumerated all
the things like the principles they
believed in and I was very young and I
uh
came away thinking it was a left-leaning
fellowship that kind of corresponded to
a lot of the things I agreed with and it
was run by the Koch Institute which is
not left laning as you might imagine but
having little familiarity with politics
but an interest I was like oh this is
really speaking to me
um and I applied and got in and was like
oh you know someone who always kind of
felt very politically homeless like this
really fits you know
adhering to these principles that they
have laid out which like I said uh
you know
analyzed outside of a confirmation bias
I thought leaned to the left which was
kind of an interesting lesson and how we
perceive political actors these days but
I did that Fellowship which was
libertarian fellowship and like I said
it was like wow this is really speaking
to me and reason was a part of it I
didn't work at reason but I immediately
became enchanted with you all and
started freelancing
with Peter suterman who's our features
editor and then the internship and down
here
that's great uh Billy thank you so much
for joining us and uh thanks for your
work uh what are your uh do you have any
big whales that you're going after in
2023
yeah well I just wrote a long uh feature
on absolute immunity so one of the
things I've written a lot about at
reason is qualified immunity uh one of
the yeah there we go um this is actually
the first piece I wrote for reason and
qualified immunity which was like gosh
was that three and a half years ago so
this was before it really like bust onto
the political scene and I will say that
this is kind of emblematic of one of the
things that is so great about working
out reason and I think the Bragg
Brothers of this too is that we're able
to tell stories that I think a lot of
other media Outlets either choose to
ignore or have to ignore because of time
constraints when I was writing my
qualified immunity there was no such
thing as a qualified immunity beat it
was like me and one other person at
Forbes who was an unpaid contributor so
um this has been something that has been
you know very consequential to my time
at reason and I'm kind of expanding that
out and looking at how those sorts of
accountability doctrines are applied to
other people in the criminal justice
system or just government actors
generally whether it is a prosecutor or
you know immunity documents applied to
corrupt college officials that violate
Free Speech rights and that sort of
thing so
looking at how we hold our government
accountable
yeah you know when I really appreciate
that you've been on this qualified
immunity issue you know like a dog with
a bone um because it's it's really
important
um and uh you know uh uh CJ is another
person at reason who covers a lot of um
you know uh law enforcement and kind of
like uh prison official accountability
um and I know you've said elsewhere that
you know qualified immunity
uh by itself while it's an important
issue it's definitely not like the whole
it's one piece of the puzzle so I was
wondering if you could talk about like
what what is like your larger project
when you think about
um Criminal Justice Reform like how do
you want to change how people are
thinking about like the relationship
between citizens and you know State
officials or law enforcement uh and
criminal justice officials sure that's a
good question and something I think
about a lot in the context of a national
debate that seems to have devolved into
either back the blue no matter what and
like Apollo Shore Define the police I
mean I I don't I actually very much
don't believe that those two sides
represent the median-american voter I
mean if you look at the data they
definitely don't but those are the two
sides we hear from most because they're
interesting and the media is interested
in covering points of view that are
fascinating
um I think what I am most interested in
is shy running a light on how the people
who enforce the laws are often above
them and how convoluted and perverse
that is especially if you believe in the
Constitution and you believe in
responsible accountable government which
is typically
a stance taken up by Libertarians as
well as the right for some reason the
right kind of suspends those principles
when it comes to law enforcement because
we are embroiled in a never-ending
culture War
um
and so I think that is what I'm most
trying to say to people you know I guess
that message needs to be heard more by
people who are right-leaning and a
little skeptical of government
accountability when it comes to the
police but I would say to people like
that if you believe in responsible
governance and that should be applied do
you know like like I said a corrupt
College administrator for instance then
why shouldn't it be applied to the
people who have a monopoly on force and
power it simply doesn't make sense and
then I mean to the left I would say that
you can apply these principles without
necessarily have to burn like to burn
everything down you know obviously
there's room for discussion on like how
much how many where resources go that
sort of thing but I also think that
there will always be a need for law
enforcement and you know the government
does in some sense have to hold us
accountable but if they do the people
who told us accountable can't be
unaccountable in doing so that's another
reason why I'm interested in things like
you know civil forfeiture civil
forfeiture it's essentially legalized
larceny people who are not familiar with
that term
and it is a lever that is pulled by the
government when they are trying to hold
alleged law Breakers accountable but it
is a completely unaccountable process
which is a paradox I can't ignore
well thank you Billy uh both for talking
to us today but also joining a a kind of
legacy of people like Jacob solemn like
Radley Balco like CJ serum CEO romella
Mike Riggs I had reason in talking about
Criminal Justice Reform and putting it
in a uniquely libertarian perspective
which you know Zach at the beginning of
this Telethon talked about how you know
the libertarian lens allows for a
different kind of brighter type of light
to be shined on a lot of things that you
know if you're embroiled in you know
liberal or conservative Progressive or
right-wing politics you're not going to
see so thanks so much for your time and
for your work and we're looking forward
to that big story that you're talking
about I appreciate it it's a legacy I am
honored to be a part of thanks for
having me on thanks and uh while uh up
next is uh Robbie Suave uh for reason
we're going to get to him he's coming to
us I think from our DC HQ uh but I do uh
take the time to donate go to reason.com
donate and make a tax deductible gift
that supports Billy Binion's journalism
as well as all of our efforts here at
reason you can also Don edit YouTube on
the bottom of the page
to emphasize that there's a button on
YouTube that you can use to donate and
that is the method to do your tax
deductible donation that'll go 100 to
reason so thank you to everyone who's
been using that all right let's uh go to
Robbie Suave uh and uh Robbie thanks for
talking to the reason on our live stream
uh uh during our Telethon webathon hey
guys thanks for having me
hey uh let's start with uh uh what was
your uh what did you feel was your best
piece over the past year
I think I'm happiest with the interview
I got to do with Dr fauci uh for my show
Rising I host this YouTube show for the
hill and I feature lots of reason people
on it actually because Zach was on just
yesterday earlier this week talking
about FTX and
SPF yeah that whole thing to uh really
educating myself and my viewers about
crypto and Liz Wolfe has been on a lot
Elizabeth Nolan Brown Etc but uh yeah I
was able to interview Dr fauci probably
it was a couple months ago I think it
was in the summer and I was able to
write uh you know write about that
interview for a reason and it was that
was one of our most visited pieces right
I think in the past year uh Zach do you
want to run that uh clip if we have it
uh just it's a taste of this from rising
stringent
yep here comes and there would have been
much much more stringent uh restrictions
in the sense of very very heavy
encouraging people to wear masks
physical distancing or what have you
many experts I think have conceded that
at least the cloth masks are not doing
virtually anything to stop the spread I
think there's you know questions
increasingly questions about whether
these restrictions are making much of a
difference and then some of them are you
know quite uh quite difficult for for
people with disabilities for children
having to wear them in schools what is
your view of ongoing restrictions do you
still think they're necessary would you
still recommend those types of things
masks you know some social distancing
some shutdowns given that you know we're
going to be facing this this disease at
this level of contagiousness for some
time
um
that was that's uh great TV I recommend
people go to YouTube to the risings uh
Channel on YouTube and watch the whole
thing and read Robbie's piece of
reason.com Robbie what's it like I mean
you know Anthony fauci is you know one
of the great villains of the current
drama but he's also very powerful like
what's it like to speak truth to power
like that
I think he really deserves frankly that
label a villain you saw a little bit of
it there if he could do it all over
again I think most people many people
think we could do it all over again a
lot of things would have been different
schools would have stayed open
um et cetera et cetera and so on but his
takeaway is that no we needed to lock
down harder we need to mask harder we
need to social distance harder it's
clear he has some uh some admiration for
what they've been able to do in China
pursuing the zero coveted policy
something that now you know people
languishing under much much greater
tyranny than any of us have ever come
close to facing they are rising up and
demanding their freedoms and it's it's
very admirable and I think it it says
something that so many of our own
government Health advisor officials
um dream about what they could do with
greater State capacity to use the
kindest way of describing that sort of
authoritarianism Robbie I mean I feel
like you and I and several other people
at reason were like
met like years ago like starting to bang
our heads against the wall with a lot of
this stuff um whether it was kind of the
Persistence of various covid
restrictions past any like sensible
utility or like justification also kind
of like the policing of discourse around
questions like around the lab leak uh
Theory which you raised with fauci as
well in that interview like how do you
view
um you know reasons role in that
conversation and I guess specifically
like your role as a commentator at
reason is being able to kind of question
that conventional wisdom uh well also
you know The Balancing Act of um there's
lots of like legitimately crazy people
um out there speculating about things
well look I think it's become very clear
that a lot of Critics on the right of of
the the policing of the discourse on
social media where so many of us live
and we're so much important discussion
of public policies taking place the
right and well some elements the left
the contrarians were very right that the
rules were being set in bad places to
limit conversations but where where they
aired was in concentrating on what the
social media platforms have done that's
wrong and and then their Solutions have
been terrible what if let's break them
up let's put the government in more in
charge of what they're going to do let's
punish them we are just beginning to and
I think reason all of us have really
been at the Forefront of understanding
how at the root of so many of these bad
decisions was the federal government was
the CDC was the Department of Justice
was National Security advisors if you're
talking about the you know the Russian
misinformation Etc at every turn and I'm
working on actually a big story for us
right now it'll be in our magazine I'm
just just putting the finishing touches
on it really looking in deep and I got
some original documentation that I'll be
excited to share of how uh government
officials were inconstant contact with
social media companies encouraging
pushing terrible moderation decisions
that limited all of our ability to
discuss the pandemic and other subjects
in in thoughtful Nuance in true ways so
that's something I think Libertarians
bring to the to the table that to to
re-set the conversation where it should
be or the criticism toward what big
government has done to Big Tech it's not
just the platforms it's it's the
government one of the uh one of the
gifts that you can get if you donate if
you make a tax deductible donation of
Reason go to reason.com day night if
you're on YouTube smash that donate
button at the bottom of our Channel page
uh is Robbie's Tech Panic which is about
the freak out I mean really a moral
Panic a technological panic over social
media because people are pissed about
other things and they're trying to break
up Facebook you know which is meta now
and you know they'll get all of these
companies is in their crosshairs just as
people have left them on mass it seems
um Robbie one of the things that's going
on now you know with Elon Musk taking
over Twitter and Twitter just today
announced or there were a bunch of
stories about how it's not going to
um you know enforce covid misinformation
policies and you can see people's heads
exploding all over the place
um why is Free Speech in the tech space
in the social media space so important
oh it couldn't be more important this is
where so many conversations about public
policy are taking place this is where
journalists live it is true and it's not
true in the legal sense that like
Twitter is the new Public Square but I
think it's basically true in a kind of
philosophical sense and and look we
should not limit these companies rights
to to do moderation as they see fit and
I think someone like Elon Musk has
articulated uh some some good policies
and wants to reverse some things I think
we're really bad about how Twitter was
being run he's doing it in a very
frenetic and chaotic way uh I I that but
I think we should give it time to see
how this Vision uh it turns out but if
if we lose and I think and we've seen
what happened I mean the pandemic is
just such a clear example of the vast
expansion of government ability to
regulate speech of armies of bureaucrats
behind the scenes having significant
input about what you're allowed to say
about true subjects you were not allowed
to discuss to make reference to the lab
leak for months on Facebook now that's a
theory that has enough mainstream
credibility that we're allowed to
address it that mainstream reporters are
talking about it but journalists a
mainstream journalists in a very I think
harmful and almost self-sabotaging way
have decided that misinformation is the
great crisis of our time that was their
explanation for why Hillary Clinton won
over Donald Trump not that Donald Trump
won rather than Donald Trump yeah I was
given what the mainstream media view of
it is of course Hillary won but
misinformation you know stop them and I
that was I think a really
um unhealthy way of viewing it but
they've become just obsessed with it and
we
go ahead I was going to say uh the story
that you're most proud of when we asked
everybody you know what what's your
favorite story of the past year what's
your favorite story with your time and
reason you picked uh the piece you know
this is a it was a massive signature
piece for you and it's very much in in
kind of Reason tradition of kind of
showing a larger story that people
missed uh Zach can we put up the uh
however this has had to do with the
Covington Catholic Student uh Nick
Sandman who was uh you know caught in a
Maelstrom can you talk a little bit
about what the story was and why did you
get the pick why did you get the full
picture while everybody else was kind of
you know holding on to a different part
of the elephant and kind of going
nowhere with it yeah and I always try to
be completely honest I got lucky in part
with this story I absolutely did I sat
down to write about it so this was the
uh the high school students the Catholic
High School students at the Lincoln
Memorial who were there was a lot of
reporting on a snippet of video footage
that appeared to show this young man
staring down this Native American man in
a malicious or racist way and they were
they were condemned by every figure
every celebrity who said these are the
example this is an example of deplorable
America obviously their Trump supporters
they're wearing the red hat they were
there for a pro-life rally
um I sat down to write about it and at
the time I was doing that a lot more
video footage had become available had
just appeared on social media the entire
thing so I sat and I watched it before I
read before I wrote anything and as I
was watching it it was like a holy crap
moment like there was so much more going
on here including the involvement of the
Black Hebrew Israelites which is like a
black supremacist anti-semitic Kanye
would probably be very familiar with
their work uh at this point they were on
the scene harassing actually the group
of of uh of boys and then the Native
American man and his Entourage come in
in like a very confusing way and the
scene becomes chaos but the bottom line
being that this was not at all it would
not be fair to say that that kid in
particular or really anyone else in his
group was like engaged in racial
harassment of that guy if anything they
were kind of behaving as appropriately
as you would expect High School boys to
behave when confronted by as obnoxious a
a out and out hate group as the Black
Hebrew Israelites so I was really happy
to be able to set the record straight on
that story a lot and again I got lucky I
I saw it and then I wrote that story and
then mine became the main part of like
the the pushback from people saying oh
wait did you take a second look at this
see what Robbie's saying about it so it
was uh it felt good and yes has been a
the defining story of my career by far
you know go ahead when you put that out
there there was also an immediate uh
backlash and you essentially became part
of the story I remember this happening
at the time I mean what was that like
like what was that experience like for
you and how did it change you know how
you view I guess like the media
ecosystem if at all
yeah I mean I've gotten really used to
that by now and even at that point I'd
had so many sort of antagonistic
exchanges with people who are just very
bought into their narratives and some in
the mainstream media some in Progressive
media obviously I've Tangled with
conservative media as well uh in that
case a lot of mainstream media admitted
they got it wrong like Jake Tapper
shared my article and said wow I missed
this
um a lot of people changed course some
didn't in the sort of like Gawker space
I think is where they really doubled
down
um you know as they did in sort of
previous feuds I'd had with them but I I
yeah I look I have a pretty hostile
antagonistic relationship I think with
many other facets of the media and I
think that's that's our job look they
they both sides it's right and left and
then mainstream too they have they
they're just stuck in their thinking
about issues about Trump about crime
about uh foreign policy is the most you
know consensus just totally at odds
without with what actual people think
um and and what I love about reason and
you know what all of us work toward is
because we're not team loyal like if I
see a story that's damaging to
Republicans there's a lot of
conservative media people who'll be like
well let's skip over that one and then
it's the opposite phenomenon for for uh
the mainstream and progressives I just
don't have that I don't have that drive
and neither do you guys right we're like
okay if it's damaging to Republicans
that's fine good they deserve it
probably you know this uh you know and
uh to go back to how Zach had started
this live stream for people watching and
if you're thinking about supporting
reason you know we do journalism first
and foremost from a Libertarian
perspective so it informs our starting
point but we're not ideologues
um and I think that gives us a
competitive Advantage I mean Robbie in
the in the uh Covington uh school kids
uh story really came to the fore but
like where you the rush to judgment
isn't there there it's like okay let's
pan back a little bit and see what's
going on we've done that I'm working on
a post for our website to you know pimp
the webathon tomorrow and one of the
very first reason stories I remember
reading was from 1981 About Love Canal
which was a neighborhood in in uh
Niagara Falls New York there was a media
narrative about it that turned out to be
completely wrong and reason was the one
place that actually accounted for a
larger context which radically altered
you know what these stories mean and
that's
um it's just it's a real powerful super
weapon so thank you very much for doing
what you do you've really uh enriched
the uh the pages of Reason uh you know
online and offline the work at the
rising is great you're really uh growing
the audience for a Libertarian reason
style uh commentary and journalism
thanks so much we've got to come in here
echoing that uh Lucas love you on the
hill Robbie though not sure how you get
along with your co-hosts sometimes with
the wild stuff free says uh you know you
you've got really good chemistry with
her that was a good uh I I thank you for
having me on by the way uh she you both
ask good questions
um she
um was asking some challenging questions
about uh regulation Financial regulation
and uh the crypto space but yeah what
could you talk just a little bit about
that that specific Dynamic and just you
know kind of venturing out into the
world of uh engaging in a really like
pointed way with people who
fundamentally disagree with you yeah
it's uh every day is uh is a wild one at
Brianna my co-host uh for for most of
the time of a couple other co-hosts as
well Brianna Joy gray is a former press
secretary for Bernie Sanders she's a
Democratic Socialist so we have areas of
agreement on foreign policy uh even some
aspects of covet I would say for some
lot of free speech stuff but we also
disagree passionately about a number of
things student loans we fight we fight
to the death on student loan forgiveness
she's wildly in support of it I think
you know this is a scandal and at the
very least if we're going to do it we
have to reform the entire higher
education sector that's another
conversation but uh it but it but it's
fun and we have actual debates and so
much of mainstream media is just you
know I don't mean to sound like a broken
record and keep bashing them but you
turn on cable news and it's just people
who agree with each other telling the
audience what they want to hear and we
try not to do that I think and I think
in the same way the reason tries not to
do that obviously we have an audience
that's interested in our perspective and
I I it helps to bring that perspective
of skepticism of authority and
skepticism of government regulation and
that the government's always the
solution but it's healthy to get to get
pushback at all times so I'm able to
deploy libertarian arguments against
Brianna she's able to deploy Progressive
or socialist arguments against me and I
think it makes us better for it and hope
hopefully leads to a more educated
smarter more fun viewing experience it's
not it's not agreement you don't just
watch and listen to everyone tell you
exactly what you wanted to hear and I
think that has value it certainly does
thanks so much Robbie thank you guys
all right uh we uh I'm just looking at
some comments we're going to bring on
our final guest which who is Elizabeth
Nolan Brown in just a second but Keith
Knight of the libertarian Institute says
way it's a Libertarian Institute are
very appreciative of the work you guys
do uh Tony palmantera on Facebook says I
will say wise Mueller's pieces stick out
in my memory the multi-part series on
Anarchy in Detroit in particularly yeah
and we'll talk more about that after we
talk to Elizabeth uh lee mccracklin a
hundred dollar don't uh donation thanks
so much
um let's bring is Elizabeth's uh I think
she's we're about 10 minutes away from
Liz coming in okay so uh I apologies for
that yeah let's talk about you Zack wise
Miller why not okay Florida born and
bred moved to LA back in Florida you've
uh uh I mean you've contributed
massively in the decade plus that you've
been at reason what was your favorite
video that you put out this past year
there's a video that I put out called
forget the great reset uh Embrace The
Great Escape and I this this is an
example of what I was talking about
earlier when I said that reason allows
like a level of experimentation that is
really useful we've kind of experimented
with a new form of video that is you
know I mean it's it's it's native to the
YouTube flat platform kind of known as
the video essay and you're just bringing
in all sorts of archival media and uh
text and so forth and making an argument
and um in this case uh it ended up you
know performing well beyond massively I
mean yeah yeah let's uh look at a clip
okay
of the great reset in which sclerotic
20th century institutions accumulate
even more power I think we're entering
The Great Escape this is possible
because technological progress is
outpacing the ability of the state to
control and regulate it governments will
have no choice but to abandon their
efforts to construct physical and
metaphorical walls technology can be
designed to facilitate decentralization
in which the flow of money and
information can't be controlled ideas
emerge from the bottom up my hope
is that after witnessing the Colossal
failure of governments in the face of a
global crisis many more people will be
looking for a different approach
Cloud Schwab of course is the head of
the world economic forum and a pretty
much a villain from Central Casting
whenever he opens his mouth about you
know what kind of bugs yeah let me just
play like a quick click a quick look of
him to remind people uh coronavirus
pandemic has no parallel in modern
history
defining moment those are the words of
Klaus Schwab head of the world economic
Forum in covid-19 the great reset people
assume we are just going back to the
good old world which we had
and everything will be normal again in
how we are used to normal in the
old-fashioned this is let's say fiction
it will not happen at the latest War
yeah it's like a Boys from Brazil
cosplay or something like that it's just
uh but you know what what's great about
your video is that you take seriously
the the arguments that are floating
around you know Schwab is probably the
best focal point for one of them but a
large number of people and you know he
at the world economic Forum he was
introducing Xi Jinping of China who was
articulating a vision of a globally
coordinated economy where you know we're
speeding it up we're slowing it down
we're a little to the right a little to
the left I mean an insane lunatic
fantasy of control by the Globes you
know the planet's leading authoritarian
um you take their argument seriously and
then offer an alternative
um you know talk a little bit how you
got there what's your intellectual
Heritage that you
um you know you were able to Marshal
this kind of analysis and alternative
yeah so I decided uh you know the this
idea of Klaus Schwab as this kind of
Nefarious character which yes he plays
into that with his mannerisms and
sometimes very odd like stylistic
choices middle European uh accent and
all of that the shaved head publishing a
book called The Great reset uh as we're
in the midst of this uh pandemic
um so it's per you know lots of anxiety
online and I decided to just read
through the book and see what it was all
about
um and it's it's a fairly boring
um book with like very like almost uh
like corporate like uh HR speak type
language but when you like dig down into
it it's really about we need a a more of
a managed economy we need more things
like ESG what they call you know
stakeholder capitalism
um and uh this is something Elizabeth
Warren is a big advocate of and uh you
know my I guess you to answer your
question my like intellectual interests
are in people like Hayek and so I
thought let's cut just there's a real
stark contrast here between these two
visions let's just put them next to each
other
um Schwab's great reset versus kind of a
hayekian inspired Great Escape and it'll
be kind of like this is the tone that I
would like to see set for you know the
rest of the 21st century instead of the
one that Schwab and the w e f and Xi
Jinping want to set what is amazing to
me and because I'm a thousand years old
uh you know we had this exact
conversation
50 years ago 70 years ago 100 years ago
you know and it was Hayek versus kind of
planners not necessarily totalitarian
planners or even fully centralized
plantings but people like John Kenneth
Galbraith uh you know a popular
Economist in mid-century America who
talked about how the only way forward
the only way to be efficient and
effective was to manage capitalism in a
way where the best and the brightest you
know coming out of a
mid-century you know Kennedy fantasy of
control would you know we can we we
don't you know we've beaten the market
we've got enough smart people with
enough adding machines we can figure it
all out and that all fell apart as it
was being articulated by you know kind
of liberal Progressive planners
sometimes conservative planners because
there's a right-wing variation on this
lunatic fantasy control uh control
fantasy
um so it's it's great to see you
articulating the rebuttal to that in um
you know in real time in the language of
the current moment
um talk a little bit I mean we we I
guess mentioned a little bit about how
you shut up and reason but you know what
what's from your childhood or you know
life that I mean pointed you in a
direction where you're like I my
[ __ ] detector is going a little bit
crazy right now
um well I I think it's just uh you know
the the I started uh we had this
conversation with um Camille a few weeks
ago about how his libertarianism kind of
started with like an interest in
skepticism I kind of had that same
journey I was interested in like the the
skeptic movement
um and then that kind of led me to
libertarianism
um and then Hayek really is the ultimate
skeptic in a lot of ways he's the
skeptic of any sort of
um Central planning Because he believes
that you know once you get further and
further away from like the primary
source of information the less like
legible it becomes and that's why I
think his ideas have actually come
become even more vital than when he was
writing you know in the in the 30s and
40s and yeah we had that big disruption
in the mid-century between the
Depression and World War II which
created this you know modern are in like
technocratic state that we all live
under and Schwab's point is like okay
pandemics is like the next the pandemic
is like the next disruption and that is
going to increase the power of the state
but my thought and and my hope and and I
think there's basis for this is that
it's different this time because of the
technological situation the way that uh
technology whether it's um you know
cryptocurrencies or encrypted
communication or cheap cameras embedded
everybody is caring you know where we
both carry a monitoring device that you
know the state knows where we are at
every minute of our day because of
phones but it also carries the camera
that we use to you know to reveal what
the government is doing to people
um we're going to come back in a final
episode after we talk to Liz Nolan Brown
about some of your work uh from a couple
years ago that you're particularly in
rightly proud out of going to Hong Kong
and we'll talk more about the
centralization decentralization issue
but now let's welcome Elizabeth Nolan
Brown hey hey how you doing Liz good to
see you you are calling in from uh
Southwestern Ohio from I'm calling you
from Cincinnati and I need to say up
front that I just got a filling
today so my mouth is still sort of
Droopy so I I'm not like having a stroke
or anything I just uh well it would be
terrible if you did have a stroke now
because we wouldn't know right and we
wouldn't be able to come it's true
so uh Liz you are a senior editor at
reason is that right yes okay and you
started uh and I feel bad for not having
actually written all of this down ahead
of time and I know that I was directly
implicated in many of the hiring today
when did you start a reason I started in
2014 the same year as uh Robbie and
Slade we were we were the 2014 cohort
okay so that's like uh the you know
there's a famous uh graduating year of
quarterbacks in the mid 1980s when they
graduated from college that's kind of a
good year for reason then right
um what uh what is the story in the past
year that you are most proud of
um I'm really happy with the story it's
actually from our January uh 20 our
upcoming January issue but it's out now
online for subscribers already so you
guys should subscribe yeah also you
should donate if you should also donate
what we're talking about go to
reason.com I make a tax deductible
donation hit the button on our YouTube
channel yeah but Liz uh Nolan Brown
you're in defense of algorithms what's
that about algorithms are even more
rotten than Klaus Schwab in the world
yeah um that's that's what we hear from
all sides so uh this was a really fun
piece to write because
um you know just a lot of what people
say about algorithms there's so much you
know that they're destroying our
democracy they're making us um more
polarized they're causing depression
they're making teens commit suicide
there's just this endless Litany of
things that get attributed to algorithms
these days they sound almost like
witches yes they are they're basically
like Tech spells cast via social media
companies is is what you the impression
you get um and if you if you look at
research
um a lot of you know not only does that
not pan out and not turn out to be true
a lot of times the opposite is true
there's a lot of research about how
algorithms actually
um you know make people turn people away
from radicalization on on sites like
YouTube that they social media consumers
are better informed and you know less
polarized than people who get most of
their news from say TV or things like
that so this is just sort of uh it goes
through a bunch of the different myths
about about social media and internet
algorithms and sort of uh systematically
debunks them I
think I feel like
um something that you and I have in
common Liz is like a lot of our work a
lot of our work uh focuses on like these
tools that and tools inherently can be
used uh to build something or to destroy
something or just be destructive you
know they're double-edged uh why is that
something
um that you find yourself returning to
um yeah I mean that's exactly what I
write in this like I mean in its Essence
an algorithm is just a tool it can be
deployed in you know in good or bad ways
um I think it's because you know we we
see both sides of U.S politics just very
opportunistically demonize new tools and
new technologies because you know people
don't know a lot about how they work and
so it's very easy for them to latch onto
I think especially when it comes to like
new tech tools and say like oh like this
thing that you don't like or this thing
that we say we can fix like if we just
do this and people are like okay I don't
really know what an algorithm is or or
or you know any of these these other
sorts of things cryptocurrency is is
another good example just and it's easy
for people to demonize and I think that
you know one of the things we're
obviously very drawn to at reason across
the board is poking holes in in
conventional wisdom that is that is just
wrong and overly politicized
and there's been you know you've written
a lot about uh the battles of our
section 230. uh there's so much
um kind of Anger from uh members of both
the major political parties towards
social media for uh kind of different
reasons
um but uh you know what what uh do you
think like Libertarians um bring to that
debate that is is different than kind of
what we hear over and over from you know
the Ted Cruz's or Amy klobuchares of the
world yeah I think we are we are unique
in that we have pretty much the only
principled perspective on this um this
is why I'm really glad for the work that
I'm allowed to do on Tech policy a
reason because uh it seems like at most
other Publications either they just sort
of reflexively jump into Tech Panic or
they only defend the rights of um you
know Tech businesses and the people who
run them if they agree with their side
so like Democrats are like really happy
with when Twitter is um you know Banning
coveted misinformation they're like yeah
we're gonna defend Twitter's rights and
then when Twitter is like okay we're
gonna you know stand up for some free
speech they're like ah you know we
weren't gonna haul them before a
congressional hearing and you have
Republicans started doing that in in the
opposite way too and I think you know
reason is one of the few Outlets that
just sort of takes a principle defense
of free speech and free markets and
private Enterprise when it comes to tech
companies even if they're making
decisions we don't necessarily agree
with
could you talk a little bit about your
journalism background because
um yeah I mean you you've worked a lot
of different places uh including you
know Health uh kind of Health uh
journalism companies AARP the magazine
for the gerundocracy which I
hopefully we'll be able to join if I can
live a few more years but um yeah talk
uh how did you get started in journalism
and uh how did you end up at reason
yeah I mean I was on my high school
newspaper but then I was a theater major
in college
um I was a playwriting major I got out I
was gonna do that but I was like there's
no money in that and I don't want to
just work like a you know a waitressing
job while trying to make it in theater
so you know I maybe I can go back to
journalism I've was always pretty good
at it uh so I I got a job at a legal and
financial newspaper in Columbus Ohio and
it was actually the most amazing
education because like every day I had
to write about different court cases
that were happening in in the county or
the state and I just read a ton of
decisions and I mean now like so much of
my work still is very much informed by I
cover a lot of you know legal cases and
I think I got that sort of crash course
in that working at this newspaper in
Ohio
um like you said I I went on I I went to
grad school in DC and I I was a research
assistant for this guy who was a baby
boomer scholar so um I was a baby boomer
scholar like he was teaching a class to
like Millennials at the time about Baby
Boomers and like he wrote a book called
the greater generation which is like a
really ballsy title and that's about how
really the Boomer uh the baby boom is
the great generation and the their
parents were kind of pieces of garbage
yeah that's that was his thesis
um I somehow turned that into a job
working for five years at the AARP which
was very strange but um the uh the AARP
the magazine is one of the largest
circulation Publications on the planet
though yes it is it is it was actually
you know people really talked to you
when you worked at the AARP magazine at
least which was just sort of interesting
they gave and I realized this is a bit
off topic but [ __ ] it uh you know I'm
one of the hosts they had the best
interview with Bob Dylan Like about 5 or
10 years ago where it was he released an
album it was the only interview they
gave and they were like you know
um you know what do you think about love
or something and he was like you know
love is like water it just slips through
your hand and then you wonder if it was
ever there at all it's like the darkest
bleakest interview with the greatest
icon of you know the baby boom it was
just wonderful stuff but what kinds of
stuff did you cover for AARP and then
how did you how did you end up at reason
uh so I mean I wanted to work at reason
back then I was I was in DC and I I but
there was never a job that was like
entry level at that time and you know I
was just getting started um and then I
and so I switched and you know I covered
a lot of Health stuff for ARP and I
ended up then going and working at some
Women's Health bugs covering like
nutrition and women's health issues for
a few years um but I always wanted to
work at reason uh and so in in 2013 I uh
job I saw it opened up as a staff editor
and I applied and I got it um so I was
very excited all right good luck
um how did you grow up libertarian or do
you I mean do you consider yourself
libertarian how did or how did how did
that evolve uh well I mean it turns out
my dad is very libertarian like he voted
for a lot of libertarian candidates but
my parents are both very um you know
they're
midwesterners you know Suburban Ohio but
they they really are the quintessential
sort of Ohio swing voters too but when
you talk to them a lot of their opinions
are very libertarian even though neither
of them has ever necessarily identified
that way
um so much so that I didn't know it was
a thing until after college and I was my
very first job out of college was a very
boring um administrative job and I was
just like sitting there all day like
applying for anything and anything I
could find online that I thought might
like get me somewhere else uh and I saw
the institute for Humane studies some
are some are seminars that they used to
do for um college students and recent
graduates and it was like I went to
Washington DC it was like a week-long
crash course in libertarianism they gave
me a subscription to reason magazine
they gave me Jacob Solomon's book they
gave me a bunch of uh Cato Institute
Scholars books and um I was like it was
just you know like wow this is what I've
been this is what I've been all along I
just didn't know this was a thing I used
to just think like I don't fit anywhere
in politics and so it was it was
eye-opening wow
um your favorite story uh uh
from your time at reason is a cover
story from a few years ago
um the war on sex trafficking is the new
War on Drugs can you tell us a little
bit about what what's that story about
and how did you come to write it
yeah um it was I came to write it
because it was just like me and
Catherine and Peter and the reason
desiapa is discussing how I was like you
know I cover I was covering a lot of the
war on sex work and how it was you know
um being sort of portrayed as a war on
sex trafficking and how so many of the
things that they were doing seemed like
a lot of the things escalating in the
same way that the War on Drugs had
escalated in terms of you know using on
the prospect of sex trafficking as a as
a reason to do catch-all Vice things as
a reason to fund more Federal money to
local police squads and give them more
equipment and do these like task forces
as a reason to um you know make
sentences much more Draconian as a
reason to pass new at laws on asset
forfeiture as an excuse to do more
surveillance of people overall
um it was just very much in the same way
that you know this people they were
using sex trafficking as a reason to
expand the police state in the
surveillance State essentially
um and so a lot of my work I've done in
the past eight or nine years now at
reason has been on this same theme but
this was the first big piece where we
sort of laid it all out and you know uh
talked about how this idea that we were
in the middle of a human trafficking
epidemic was overblown and how it was
being used as a political excuse by a
lot of people and where that came from
and what the effects were and I think
this this makes the first sort of
comprehensive case for this and again
just it's the kind of work that I could
only do at reason I think now that
there's a lot more acceptance for the
idea that that you know a lot of what's
called sex trafficking busts or human
trafficking bust is actually just
prostitution busts or generalized Petty
Vice busts or excuses for surveillance
but like back in 2014 2015 that was not
an idea that was out there at all and
people were really you know reacting
sort of like very negatively to it on a
lot of people because they were just
like what you're saying that like you
know sex trafficking isn't a real
problem which is not you know what we
were saying um I think that we actually
really helped turn the tide on this
conversation
um
what um two things uh and I was just
talking about that story or your work
with somebody the other night
um one of the things you you have
created heuristic for me anytime I read
a story or see something about okay
there's a big sex trafficking bust it's
like book book market and then come back
in a month or two months and see what's
happening inevitably the only arrests
that have been made were of women for
prostitution nothing ever gets higher
beyond that
um but then the other question I guess
or the uh you know and that's just a
great thing like people should do that
all the time because bookmark it and
come back to it but what um where did
the hysteria over sex trafficking come
from in a United States context because
we hear about this now all the time it
is really driving it's driving a lot of
Internet uh you know policy it is
driving all sorts of um you know kind of
government policies Etc and there is a
cultural sense that we have we have
never been in a situation like we are
now a midst of massive sexual
trafficking of minors of young boys of
young girls of foreigners of this or
that even though there's essentially no
evidence uh you know that it is an
epidemic it's it happens and it needs to
be dealt with but why are we why are we
stuck in this narrative Loop yeah there
is like you said there's absolutely no
evidence that this is you know becoming
more of a problem that it's more
widespread than it ever was if anything
it's less widespread um but it was it
was actually a really concerted effort
by the say people that brought us the
porn wars in the 80s and 90s and they
sort of realized that they were losing
on that front they realized that you
know if you look at polls back from the
90s more and more people said like yes
prostitution should be legal as long as
it's you know safe and regulated which
which is you know its own thing but uh
you know there was not as much of an
anti a puritanical anti-prostitution
attitude there was not as much of that
happening anymore and so the religious
right and anti-porn feminists got
together and they were like we are going
to specifically conflate all
prostitution with sex trafficking or
human trafficking in the UK they tend to
call it modern slavery they're like we
are specifically going to you know
conflate these things in order to get
people to turn against this and they
really there's like documents of them
sort of planning to do this
um they really were the ones that pushed
the First Federal anti-sex trafficking
law which was passed in 2000 and people
often say like oh you know we didn't
have that law until 2000 but like there
were other laws that prevented that same
thing it just wasn't we weren't calling
it sex trafficking
um but yeah they you know the the
anti-porn the Coalition of anti-porn
feminists and uh religious right got
together and really worked really hard
for the past several decades to
specifically frame it this way and make
it seem like all prostitution is you
know being done with children or being
done through force and coercion some
sometimes the argument that you hear
from decriminalization Advocates is that
you know
to taking the Law taking law enforcement
out of it would actually help with sex
trafficking you know or coerced sex to
the degree that it is a problem because
then um you know the the focus is is not
so wide it's more narrow on this this
the subset subsection of like real abuse
um do you buy that is that like part of
your reason for advocating
decriminalization
um or like what what are the main
reasons that you think that would be you
know the best way forward yeah I mean
there's obviously just the first
principle's reason like you know adults
should be able to do what they want in
the privacy of their bedrooms with their
own bodies Etc
um I think that that's very valid but
there's also yeah the harm reduction
element which is that yes it would free
up police resources because pretty much
now all of the you know anti-sex
trafficking resources are just going
through prostitution things so it's free
up police time and resources it would
mean that people could go to police sex
workers themselves their customers
people in their midst could actually go
to police and report you know crimes
right now they're just afraid of being
arrested themselves so they can't
um and it would it would just make yes
it would make everything safer overall
it would allow them to take more steps
so that they could work together they
could work in you know centralized
businesses they could screen clients
better they could do so many things that
would make the industry safer for people
no matter why they were there so it
could make you know things better for
yes people who are sex workers 100 by
choice and people who are being coursed
into it and everywhere in between
uh would you talk a little bit about uh
feminism and uh libertarianism you
you're also uh one of the founders and
heads of feminists for Liberty a group
that of libertarian feminists
um you know it's a it's a strange
movement in many ways uh arguably and
there's a new book out about this by
Timothy sanderfer but you know Ein Rand
Rose Wilder Lane and Isabelle Patterson
are kind of the three figures who kind
of start what became the modern
libertarian movement obviously all women
the movement is you know widely
stereotyped and not necessarily and
accurately as uh you know mostly male
um that I think that's changed a lot
certainly even in my nearly 30 years of
reason and whatnot but
um is you know what does it mean to be a
Libertarian feminist and um is there any
contradiction there or does it make
perfect sense in a way that critics and
allies may not fully appreciate
I think it makes perfect sense um you
know I think both libertarianism and
feminism are rooted in respect for the
individual and treating people as
individuals rather than you know uh
Collective sort of uh representatives of
their you know among other things of
their sex or gender
um but obviously there are different
kinds of feminism there have always been
different kinds of feminism they've
always been what we might call
libertarian feminists or individualist
feminists and they've always been much
more socialist and leftist feminists I
mean there's a lot of different kinds of
feminism
um I think one of the things we really
just want to do is point out that there
have though I mean there have been
libertarian oriented feminists all along
this is a legitimate and important
school of thought within feminism that
just says you know like we have the same
goals we want you know people to be
treated you know equally under the law
and in general based on you know not not
be treated certain ways because they're
women but we don't need the government
to step in and give them special
privileges and so you know I think
libertarian feminism in some places I'm
putting role in sort of countering a lot
of the what is now the mainstream
feminism but it's it's been here all
along especially in the 80s and 90s
there was a big movement of the
association of libertarian feminists
existed my favorite Joan Kennedy Taylor
wrote a lot of good books on this
um it's definitely Fallen by the wayside
the libertarian feminism movement in the
past 20 years but that's kind of one of
the things we want to do is help bring
more attention to it and revive it
are you uh is this a good time to be
either a Libertarian or a feminist I
mean it's kind of interesting yeah
uh probably not no it does not seem like
a particularly good job I mean it wait
it it's an exciting time the world needs
us Libertarians more than ever right now
I think so can I you know I obviously I
lived in Oxford Ohio which is about 30
miles north of uh Cincinnati on and off
for 20 years so I think a lot about Ohio
both you know it's kind of like a mental
territory it's the heart of it all it
used to say on its license plates it's
you know Columbus Ohio is supposedly the
most representative City every fast food
company is either based there or tries
out new food and clothing and everything
there
um Ohio and it is a Bellwether State
it's you know it's pretty purple or it
goes you know blue and red and all of
that kind of stuff
um it's you know it now has one of the
most Draconian abortion laws in the
country you know as a woman and as a
mother yeah you're uh you have a son who
is what like about a year old a little
bit more than a year
um I don't you know how do how does that
make you feel like do you feel like now
it's viscerally personal or you know or
is that well you know what the
government isn't actually very good at
doing anything including restricting my
sexual autonomy uh you know what's your
sense from you know the heart of the
heart of the country
um this isn't going to sound good it's
sort of like not real to me that I am in
Ohio in again
um like I grew up here but then I was
away for about 20 years so and I moved
back in in late 2020s so um you know it
almost feels like oh Ohio politics are
like a thing that is that is separate
for me um which I I need to get over
because they're they're definitely not
now
um yeah so I I don't think I feel it
particularly viscerally in any way but
it is very disappointing and you know it
makes me uh want to get more involved in
politics at the local at the local level
here well it could be worse you could be
in Indiana or Kentucky right I love
Kentucky we can talk [ __ ] about Indiana
all you want but like I'm gonna defend
it you know now and we mentioned
Generations in the past uh but you know
you and Zach uh Millennials are you're
just like uh you know [ __ ] moving
back home yeah we're also ancient which
is hilarious like yes I love it people
were talking about Millennials like
We're Young now you're like guys we're
like sporty yeah yeah it's it's your
best years are behind you I I'm sorry
that I had to tell you in this forum but
you know there it is well hey where you
you seem to be talking up to jaredocracy
so uh you know I go back and forth I
what I what I really describe I mean I
hate the gerundocracy and I talk a lot
about how you know growing up in the 80s
and stuff you would look at these old
Soviet leaders and you were like God
these [ __ ] people are vampires
they're a thousand years old and like
they were in their 50s and now we're
living in a place where you know people
who are 80 are you know running the
country and things like that it's
disturbing as hell but the younger
people are terrible too so it's like
it's just bad people all the way down I
suppose
uh yeah no it feels weird there's people
that I think are you know I think of as
old when I see them like people in
public figures and then I realize
they're like my age now so it's it's a
little disturbing but
um do you uh do you uh what do you have
on tap for 2023 what are your big uh
hopes for uh in terms of Reason
journalism and breakthroughs and things
like that
uh the the big thing I'm working on
right now my next big feature is about
um birth rates and how the panic over
birth rates and uh how it sort of
leading to Crazy policies uh on on both
the left and the right and yeah you know
what a Libertarian responses to that
Beyond just like don't worry about it
because that's not very satisfying to
people even though I I do think that
there's some element of you know this
represents people making their own
individual choices and we need to
respect that but also um how do we still
take into account you know possible
issues that it brings without resorting
to bigger government
um
but that's another very nuisance stages
so I don't have any answers to that yet
okay bye uh I got a couple of uh things
uh links I'll send you uh okay
uh and again you know this also
showcases kind of I think a lot of
Reason stuff ends up in a place where
it's you know the right and the left are
starting to kind of come to a consensus
on similar policies maybe starting from
very different places but you get this
both the right and the left are like you
know we really need to start using
governments in order to increase birth
rates yeah and it's kind of like yeah
that's that doesn't end well
historically or uh you know in any other
way yeah and any other countries that
have tried it it has not worked at all
either so yeah but it doesn't mean they
can't waste a lot of trouble and cause a
lot of misery right
um correct correct yeah didn't they try
to give out like free cars in Hungary or
something like that to get people to
have babies I don't know if it's hungry
but um are they doing hungry yeah I
don't know maybe there's a very long
history of that and yeah yeah and Clay I
mean you know like half of the tax code
is
kind of impregnated with uh natalist
assumptions and presumptions and things
like that too so that looks uh that'll
be something really wonderful and great
to look forward to uh thank you Liz for
you know not just joining us today but
being at reason and contributing you
know absolutely some of the most
memorable stuff that we have ever
published in our 50-plus year history
thank you thank you for having me on
today you're back
so if you find uh Liz Nolan Brown's uh
journalism compelling uh please help
support it by going to reason.com donate
uh or hitting the button if you're on
our YouTube channel hit the Donate
button your Tech your donations are tax
deductible because we're published by a
501c3 research and educational
non-profit so uh you can take a little
bit of money from the tax ban by giving
us a gift and it all goes to promoting
and producing more and more journalism
um and um that you know that's what
we're asking you to do we do it once a
year uh and this is that time thank you
to Wilhelm Billy for twenty dollar
donation
um Heather fezio says big thanks to
reason for myself and my colleagues that
Young Americans for Liberty we're so
grateful for the Fantastic work you all
do thanks Heather
yeah and uh rajkovsky says uh I love how
the parallel live stream right now is
Alex Jones hosting Nick Fuentes and
Kanye West what a hilarious
juxtaposition
now there's some truth to that I I
suppose so
um
um uh Waldo online rights enjoy the
reason Roundup keep up the great work
Elizabeth uh which is nice to hear
um big thanks to reason for myself this
is Heather Fazio talking and my
colleagues at Young Americans for
Liberty we're so grateful for the
Fantastic work you all do I thank you
that's uh really nice to hear love you
on the hill says Lucas love you on the
hill Robbie though not sure how you get
along with your co-hosts and uh
Catherine award this is uh a little bit
older but uh when Robbie was talking
about a feature uh she wrote putting the
finishing touches on that story a to
Robbie so deadlines Loom even during a
webathon Telethon Zach uh we're gonna
close out in uh in about 13 minutes or
so
um and uh you know let's go back to this
question about
um you know Hong Kong protests the great
reset and the Great Escape in 2019 you
actually traveled to Hong Kong when
protests were busting out in a big
profound way
um you know what was that experience
like and what did you find and how does
it help you make sense of what's going
on now in Hong Kong where and throughout
China actually more broadly where there
are massive ongoing demonstrations
against zero covet policy there yeah
um and I'll I'll just share uh the kind
of intro to that video quick and then
tell you some thoughts about it
the protests that have consumed Hong
Kong for more than three months started
because of a proposed bill that would
have made it easier for mainland China
to extradite citizens from this
semi-autonomous city violent clashes
between protesters and police culminated
in a confrontation at a subway station
on August 31st when police appeared to
beat demonstrators with batons possibly
resulting in one fatality though
authorities dispute that claim the
activists politicians and academics we
spoke with said that the protest
movement has become about much more than
the extradition bill which the
government has since withdrawn it's a
fight for the survival of an island of
liberalism in the shadow of an
increasingly authoritarian super state
with ambitions of global dominance we
are at the front line between the great
dictatorship among human history which
is CCP and the written world and Hong
Kong usually shows that we stand with
the freedom world and of course we hope
the rest of the freedom world can
support us in this battle in this war
between dictatorship and freedom
yeah so I mean that experience was you
know life-changing for me uh it's I I
picked it as you know one of my favorite
all-time projects just because going
there and you know first of all I'd like
everyone else been watching it from afar
with some level of Fascination and then
uh the reason TV's managing editor Jim
Epstein was like well why don't you go
and so that's again a wonderful thing
about working a reason that these
opportunities to just you know jump on a
plane and and go over and you know see
for yourself what's happening
um and you know I made it my goal
because I I knew that you know there was
lots of footage out there of the
conflict of the tear gas canisters I
just wanted to sit down and talk with
people about their values and like what
what is it that um motive is was
motivating them to go up against the
Behemoth like Chinese Communist Party
um and which uh you know at the time uh
of course had started to infiltrate Hong
Kong but
um the you know part of the story for me
and part of what you know changed me
throughout this experience was going
there kind of seeing Hong Kong on the
precipice and then over the following
few years seeing kind of the
institutions entirely crumble and be be
taken over and to see how
quickly that can happen
was alarming to me especially
as you know we had this Global cataclysm
happen just you know a year later less
than a year later
um so I don't know it just shifted the
way I saw a lot of things and
um I'm I'm grateful for to reason for
sending me there to allow me to document
it the material all of those uh Clips
are in either the show notes or you can
find them at recent TV's YouTube channel
it's uh spectacular work I mean it's
both deeply disturbing and deeply
inspiring um what do you think when you
look at the protests that we see in
China you know there are similar
similarly intense and widespread
protests going on in Iran uh for
different reasons but
um do you have a sense of like
um you know how how do protests lead to
change in China or do they
um yeah it's it's so hard to say uh you
know what happened to Hong Kong which uh
all you know at least at the time had
some uh liberal institutions the fact
that uh that was kind of swamped was it
makes me a little bit pessimistic I
gotta say but
um on the the optimistic side of me is
like well the reason this is happening
in places like Hong Kong and I mean in
China and Iran is that the the
communications technology allows this
kind of coordination I mean that was
crucial to the Hong Kong protest was the
ability to use encrypted apps to use
airdrop
um to uh you know have this uh kind of
flowing type thing that they they
adopted the Bruce Lee you know be like
water type mentality
um in China it's a lot harder because
every thing is already locked down and
unfortunately you know companies like
apple have uh you know disabled some of
the mechanisms like airdrop which we're
allowing people to get around to that
um but I I do believe that you know
technology does continue to outpace you
know in the medium to long term the um
kind of authoritarian impulses and means
of control yeah it's uh interesting
there's a great book from God I guess
it's the earlier mid 90s by Peter Huber
Manhattan Institute scholar who died a
few years ago called uh Orwell's Revenge
the 1984 palum CEST and um it uh you
know one of the starting points was that
Orwell got it wrong and that you know by
imagining surveillance is Flowing from
the you know the camera to the
surveilled people and in fact
historically that you know the real
relationship between technology and
power is much more fraught and even with
surveillance equipment and whatnot that
oftentimes that equipment ends up
getting turned around onto people you
know but now but a meaningful way I've
uh interviewed Brian Lamb over the years
several times the founder and former
head of C-SPAN and kind of talked with
him about you know he took the
surveillance camera and turned it on
Congress and like that changes things
you know but people are doing reverse
peephos all the time and that changes uh
you know it kind of changes the way
things operate do you feel
um uh you know as we wind down on this
reason annual webathon Telethon
um with our flashing lights Rattle and
reminiscent of the Jerry Lewis Telethon
are you optimistic
um you know about
the next five years I mean I think most
Libertarians I know are very optimistic
about the next 15 years or the next 50
years but about the next five years what
do you think
um I'm optimistic in certain regards I
mean I I it was great that we started
off with uh Catherine talking about you
know the Advent of commercial space
travel I mean we're we're seeing uh uh
the thing I love about that is that it's
so concrete you can just you can just
see the Rockets going up and these
boosters Landing themselves in a way
that was never possible until
um you know a company uh engineered it
to be that way so I I continue to be
optimistic about technological uh steps
forward and the way that's going to
improve our lives
um you know I just saw this thing with
open Ai and it's chat bot and its
ability to answer questions
um with like incredible detail these
things are just happening uh you just
have uh left and right you just have to
look for them and also just the kind of
increased ability of people to
choose their own adventure in life and
you know live where they want send their
kids to school where they want watch the
entertainment and like customize life to
their liking I think all that is going
in a positive direction and we'll
continue to you know the macro trends
like the economy and our like fiscal
situation and just like the General
State of our national electoral politics
I think is pretty grim and in many ways
can threaten all of that
um so I think it's it's a real mixed
picture yeah that's uh you know that's a
kind of a great thought to uh you know
kind of go out on but reason started in
1968 throughout its history
um you know it it's always recognized
that uh you know kind of Liberty or
Freedom or self-determination I guess in
a less kind of ideological term it's
never it's rare when it's happening it's
all going in the same direction like
there's always a mix and one of the
things that's fascinating to me when I
joined reason in the fall of 1993 and
October of 93 and I moved to LA and you
know I was able to see the entire
magazine run it wasn't online at the
time and it was fascinating to see in
the 70s you know which the 70s were a
terrible decade for many many things
particularly kind of broad economic
issues were not great you know there
were a lot of problems in the United
States Etc urban life was decaying
rapidly in the 1970s but there were also
all of these massive increases
culturally and in lifestyle and you know
there was so much Freedom so like on you
know the one hand things were getting
shittier on the other hand all of this
other stuff was happening in a good way
and then years later I mean we could
recognize that things like the you know
the the grand groundwork for the
personal computer Revolution which
ultimately led to the internet and
whatnot those tracks were being laid in
the 70s even as people were thinking you
know nothing good was being made anymore
in America or elsewhere so it's kind of
in reasons DNA to always be recognizing
that you know Freedom doesn't Advance
you know in a in One Direction all at
the same time
um and that there's many different types
of sources of power sources of
repression sources of innovation sources
of Liberation and it's good to always be
kind of taking in a 360 degree view
because there's a lot of awful things
going on
specifically from a Libertarian
perspective but there's also a lot of
really fantastic things going on yeah
and there's there's this shift that
we're still going through where people
are kind of trying to find their footing
of like what institutions to trust which
which ones are trustworthy a lot of that
has been you know thrown massively into
question because of the last couple
years
um I think the uh FTX meltdown is like a
kind of interesting
um example of that where this guy uh you
know ensconced himself with uh kind of
the old establishment but he was like
riding this the wave of like this new
technology of cryptocurrency and um
unfortunately yeah there's going to be a
lot of uh you know anytime there's
disruption there's gonna be some element
of tragedy and I I'm hoping that you
know the the work that that reason does
and that we do highlighting
um kind of like the the exciting and
hopefully trustworthy
um institutions that uh both have
existed for a long time and that are
emerging now
um and also uh you know trying to stick
uh to bring It full circle to the the
facts and uh you know have a
conversation uh where we can all you
know uh look at some shared set of facts
and then
um you know we might be coming from
slightly just different perspectives but
at least we're like uh committing to
having a conversation based on that that
understanding yeah I think that's a
great way to talk about it and you know
facts you know facts are arguments right
that are kind of settled arguments so
we're always going to be coming up with
new facts because things change and
things like that but rooting it in uh
you know rooting our conversations in
something concrete I always find it you
know just and I and I don't mean this in
a glib way uh or in a way that always
works to my advantage but you know when
you're arguing with people about
something like uh if you can agree to
like are there a common set of facts
that we will agree to and then go from
there like it actually is very
clarifying and sometimes there isn't
because it's either about value
judgments or reality is very murky
um if you like what you've seen today in
this reason live stream please donate
give us a tax deductible donation uh at
reason.com donate you can go there
there's a lot of different giving levels
you can give once you can give monthly
you can give a little you can give a lot
you you can hit the Donate button at
YouTube were published by a 501c3
non-profit your money goes to support
our journalism our commentary our
podcasts our videos our print
publication our website all of the
expenses that we incur with that and
what we give you in exchange are a
number of things one is that we do our
best to produce top drawer journalism
that is provocative challenging correct
provisional uh but explores a world of
free minds and free markets what are the
possibilities of that what are the
things holding us back well how do we
need to redefine libertarian in you know
in in a world that is constantly
changing we also act as your voice in
public debates over politics culture and
ideas
um we go on other shows we write for
other Publications we make the
libertarian arguments
um and we try to bring that to a whole
new generation of people particularly
our YouTube channel 41 of our viewers
are under the age of 35. it's really
important to win the next Generation
Um over to a world of free minds and
free markets where individuals are
encouraged and allowed to become who
they want to be and to change who they
want to be over time these are some of
the things that your donations give us
and before we wrap I would like to thank
one more time the one thousand dollar
Anonymous donor who we mentioned earlier
thank you so much for that and also
Harry carticalities and I apologize for
butchering your name but you coughed up
406 dollars which is incredibly generous
and will help us as will all of your
donations Zach uh do you have uh any
final thoughts
I just want to Echo that and say thank
you to everybody who uh supports our
work here I hope that the stream has
given you a sense of you know what what
that support goes towards the the vision
that you are helping to put out there
and the the journalism that uh the the
serious uh journalism uh that that uh
looks at Liberty uh both here in America
and you know across the world and uh
tries to engage with you know the most
important issues from you know a
Libertarian perspective uh thank you for
enabling that
all right well this concludes our first
ever
Telethon webathon I want to thank all of
our reason staffers who participated uh
and all of you who watch and Zach
especially for co-hosting it's uh always
our Thursdays are uh always a highlight
of my week and I hope they are of yours
too the same thanks Nick okay